if you already have children which is
the majority of people who seek out
abortions and you're worried about
poverty which is valid and you're seeing
your children not be able to eat and
you're seeing all these systemic
problems your kids are getting shot in
school these are not just fears these
are valid concerns that cause people to
say you know what i don't want to bring
a baby into this inhospitable place
where i might die and that's why i got
so frustrated and i still feel that
frustration inside of me on what i'm
calling the mouse wheel because our
aligning and deciding we agree when life
begins will not also change my stance on
what needs to happen and that abortion
needs to be accessible until we can make
sure those freaking women aren't dying
out there i think we have to get into
that conversation about how we
help women who are being coerced and
support women who are in low-income
situations or abusive relationships
giving them the help that they need
connecting them to the resources that
they deserve that's all very crucial but
i do think it's essential to establish
a starting point here you don't want to
define
when that a child in the womb is a
person except unless they're 21 weeks
old is that correct so they they don't
get legal protection and a moral status
until they are 21 weeks and that sounds
very arbitrary to me it sounds it
doesn't sound scientific it doesn't
sound fair it doesn't sound just and you
know my understanding of your position
is you're about nuance and the gray area
but you're drawing a very black and
white line in an arbitrary place and
saying because of that line a child at
19 weeks
can be live dismembered in an abortion
and you don't consider that violence and
you don't consider that 19 week old baby
even a person and my physician is saying
i don't think that's loving or just the
science is conclusive when human life
begins
and a unique individual human life
begins at the moment of fertilization
[Music]
that was lila rose and brenda davies two
advocates with very opposing views on
the topic of abortion the debate around
a woman's right to choose to end a
pregnancy bodily autonomy and babies in
the womb deserving basic human rights
and protection is a heated one but so
important and what a fire conversation
we just had
brenda is a writer podcaster and
left-leaning pro-choice christian living
in los angeles hi beautiful people
my name is brenda davies i'm the creator
of god is gray
today we're talking about abortion on
why i am a christian who votes
pro-choice
cares as much about babies at the border
as i do about babies in the womb i
believe in god and global warming the
main reason i'm pro-choice is because
abortions will happen whether they're
legal or not we are going to clarify all
of that and i want you to
read up on 1973's roe vs wade the
supreme court decision made abortion
legal until the fetus is viable
everyone's gonna say god it's not great
black and white and i was i was like i'm
gonna have to argue this for the rest of
my life it's like to protect yourself
not fully identifying as something that
is marginalized and shamed and all of
that exactly we are living in the gray
space
[Music]
i am so sick of the cliche that
pro-choice people love abortion and
don't care if the numbers increase when
an absolute provable fact our party does
more to prevent abortion than the
pro-life party ever has
[Music]
her youtube channel god is gray has over
10 million views and her work attracts a
growing audience of 250 000 people in 44
countries her debut novel on her knees
memoir of a prayerful jezebel received
rave reviews and has maintained amazon's
number one position in gender and
sexuality brenda believes that forced
birth is immoral and that abortion can
be better prevented by making this
nation a more hospitable place for new
and existing life with left-leaning
policies like gun reform taking climate
change seriously on behalf of our
children raising wages and taxing the
one percent more and solving our
nation's maternal death problem she's
passionate about educating people on
what she considers the dangers of purity
culture and she's lgbtq affirming lila a
writer speaker and pro-life activist is
the founder and president of live action
a human rights non-profit with the
largest digital footprint on the globe
for the pro-life movement this is an
abortion industry dream come true kyla
rose the president of live action don't
you feel
that your positions your extreme
positions are just forcing women toward
these more dangerous options i think
that sally we should dare to have a
better view for america and our women by
saying we shouldn't believe and have to
think that women need abortion and that
we have to kill our children to achieve
the dreams and the careers and families
that we want i think we can do better
than that as a society i think women
deserve better
it calls itself planned parenthood and
the deception begins right there
when people learn the facts of human
development in the womb when they learn
the facts of the brutality of the
abortion procedure they change
what
that is sad yeah i do i do i do change
my mind
i think we should fight at the community
level for programs that are positive
that help women if they're single
mothers we should improve the foster
care system we should improve the
adoption system so that we can welcome
children to this country instead of
seeing them as a threat and killing them
by the thousands each day
[Music]
live action exists to defend the rights
of the unborn and make abortion
unthinkable with over 5.6 million social
media followers and 1.4 billion video
views live action reaches up to 100
million people per month lila's
investigative reporting on the abortion
industry has been featured in most major
news outlets including the los angeles
times the washington post the atlantic
cbs and abc nightline she's the author
of fighting for life becoming a force
for change in a wounded world she's been
named among national journals 25 most
influential washington women under 35
and she often speaks internationally on
family and cultural issues
not many issues are more polarizing and
hated than the topic of abortion a huge
problem in this world today when
navigating opposing views on any topic
but especially one like this is how
often one side labels the other as
having poor or even evil intentions but
the reality is that most people have
pure intentions for what they think is
the most kind and helpful and
progressive and in this case what they
consider more progressive towards
equality of human rights they're just
thinking with a different lens pro-life
advocates believe in the inherent value
and human rights of the unborn
pro-choice advocates believe women
should have the right to choose whether
to continue a pregnancy or not and that
banning abortion takes away bodily
autonomy both have pure intentions
that's one reason why conversations like
this are so important to understand why
the other thinks the way that they do
the other reason conversations like this
are so integral is to get to the heart
of the issue it's easy to listen to one
side you gravitate towards and the lean
on euphemisms that sound good but is the
side you listen to really speaking the
truth and do you really have all the
facts if you aren't hearing both sides
rather than go into this conversation
determined not to change your mind what
if instead you went into the
conversation determined to understand
the way the other side thinks it's
likely you've already established some
opinions about this topic but how much
time have you listened to the other side
and the reasons they think the way that
they do
if you listen with an open heart you are
much more likely to at least understand
how and why the opposing view got to
their viewpoint and understanding brings
people together understanding creates
empathy and openness and more common
ground than what is normally found and
with authentic curiosity you may even
learn something you hadn't considered
before or even change your mind these
types of conversations are so important
yet becoming increasingly rare i value
diversity of thought and truly opposing
views are my favorite type of
conversation i personally have an
opinion about this topic but i'm going
into this discussion as the moderator my
hope is that by the end of the
conversation you can't tell which side
of the issue i land on letting you the
audience hear two really well-spoken
women on both sides of the issue speak
to their heart of the pro-life versus
pro-choice perspectives i've gotten the
pleasure to get to know both women
personally before this conversation and
i can tell you without a doubt that both
women are lovely strong and passionate
women and i respect and appreciate their
friendships
please be respectful in the comments i
want to do more opposing views episodes
in the future but it's going to be a lot
harder to organize them and get people
on board for a public discussion if the
comments are riddled with nastiness
if you are tempted to become a keyboard
warrior and say things like
anti-abortionists are anti-women's
rights and just want to control women's
bodies or pro-choices just want more
babies to die then it's clear you are
misunderstanding what the majority of
people on both sides of the issue are
thinking i urge you to strengthen the
muscle of understanding why someone
thinks the way that they do
thank you so much to lila and brenda for
coming on the show it requires a lot of
bravery and vulnerability to have such
an honest discussion openly and publicly
i'm thankful for you both without
further ado my favorite episode so far
let's get into the episode all right
welcome to the podcast everyone and
especially welcome brenda and lila thank
you so much for being here i cannot
express enough gratitude because i am
just so looking forward to this
conversation and it's so rare
to
be able to have conversations like this
especially publicly where other people
can listen and engage and really hear
each other go back and forth with like
opposing views so thank you for being
here thanks for having me thank you and
for those listening and watching we're
going to basically be doing a format
where each person is going to get to
respond to each question but i'll be
directing a lot of the questions
to a specific person but they're gonna
get to go back and forth and we're gonna
just get started
okay so my first question is in two
minutes or less explain your position
and why you are pro-choice or pro-life
so brenda why don't you go first okay
i'm gonna reference something i wrote
down because i think the language is
important
but i am
pro-reproductive rights and reproductive
justice meaning the human right to
maintain personal bodily autonomy equal
access to safe abortion
affordable contraceptions and
comprehensive sex education the freedom
from sexual violence and as defined by
sister song the right to parent the
children we have in safe and sustainable
communities
so in lieu of the inhumane
removal of a person's god-given autonomy
i am someone who focused on the efforts
of making the u.s a more habitable place
for all while focusing on pregnancy
prevention
so i wouldn't call myself pro-choice i
would say all of that
yes longer drawn out yeah what about you
well i'm 100 pro-life because i think
all human life is precious and deserves
protection whether you're an unborn
child or you're an adult or you're an
elder an elder you deserve protection
legally and you deserve to be embraced
by society and i also think that the
bonds of love that connect us are some
of the most precious things in the world
and the bond of love between a mother
and her child should be protected and
supported and never never pushed towards
violence
especially against that unborn child and
i also believe that abortion is not the
solution to any problem that a woman
faces i mean i believe in
a bodily autonomy i think that's very
important and you mentioned reproductive
rights brenda and i
i agree
we have reproductive rights as human
beings but when there's a child that's
already been reproduced reproduction has
already taken place now it's a question
of human rights for that child as well
as human rights for the mother so i
think we have to
chase after both legally and in our
society
the upholding of everyone's human rights
and never pit a mother against her child
or family members against each other but
instead acknowledge that every human
being has the same human rights and
those need to be protected and the first
human right is life the right to live
okay i think that really is a great way
to start where you show like your
foundational principles so the next like
basic question how would you answer the
question what is abortion in one
sentence lila you go first abortion is
the direct and intentional killing of an
innocent child
brenda abortion is a procedure that ends
a pregnancy
okay great
so now we're going to get into some
foundational questions that may take a
little bit for you guys to go back and
forth on because it really is the
foundation of why you guys believe the
way that you do
so my first question to you brenda is do
you believe that it is always wrong to
commit intentional violence on an
innocent human person
this is such a loaded question
especially the way it's worded i don't
think anyone should be perpetuating any
violence against anyone
and the disclaimer of innocence doesn't
bear weight to me i think everyone
should be allowed to live without
violence
um
also
i mean
that question is implying
that the abortion procedure is a violent
act against a life which
is not necessarily something i believe
i think
for me the
moral stance or the complication on when
life starts is where we really get in
the mud and the mire of things where
like as opposed to really looking at the
issues and the systemic problems that
lead to an
abortion um so i'm getting lost on the
question for a second yeah so i can just
repeat again yeah do you believe i know
it's it's worded toughly yeah like this
is a really hard one yeah because the
for anyone listening or watching too
like my intention is to word questions
in a way that like a pro-choice person
would would ask a pro-life person and a
pro-life person would ask a pro-choice
person so that that has been my
intention so so this one is do you
believe that it's always wrong to commit
intentional violence on an innocent
human person
yeah so
i don't know it's a really impossible
question i think for me to answer
because i just think fundamentally it
doesn't actually present
the issue with abortion or how we're
going to figure it out or how we're
going to solve it like it's kind of
where i'm getting in the mire of trying
to
like not get in these circular mouse
wheel kind of arguments with people
about when does life begin and when is
it
not okay to do this anymore versus
really focusing on the harm that is
being done systematically all throughout
our society that causes a woman or a
person who's pregnant to feel that this
is their only choice
okay could could i follow up yes okay
i'm like not sure
that is here so um thank you for sharing
that when you say that
um
i think you were you're saying i'm not
sure how to answer that question
originally you said you think it is
violence against innocent persons or any
persons is wrong but then you're saying
you're not sure abortion is violence um
how do you define violence
well it's the the personhood it's like
such a complicated question because
there's so many
words that you could pull out of there
and realize how complicated each one is
because a personhood for me
begins at viability that's my personal
belief and some
pro-reproductive right people wouldn't
necessarily agree with me on that same
i'm sorry yeah no go ahead so just to
understand so you're saying you can't
commit violence against
a child in the womb before 20 weeks
because you don't consider them a person
so in the case of you know an abusive
boyfriend or husband who tries to force
a miscarriage for a woman who's pregnant
in the first trimester you wouldn't
consider that an act of violence against
her first trimester baby
because it's not a person yet
i mean yeah i would i think what people
really don't understand is that i'm
sitting at this table because
abortion is something that i find very
tragic and it's something that i want
more than anything else to help be
preventable in the society i think from
top to bottom the whole situation
can cause a lot of pain and does cause a
lot of pain and i do think that it is a
moral conundrum all of these these
questions
however
i believe what i do and i champion the
right to a person's bodily autonomy and
their right to choose an abortion
because i look at a society
and a place and a system and a foster
care system and a prison industrial
complex and poverty that makes this
world less habitable for those
people that we would want to s that you
would want to see like end up in society
i'm like tripping over words because
the personhood yeah makes it complicated
but
this is going to be my hardest question
because the definitions are just really
convoluted and to me no matter how i
answer this question it doesn't really
get to the root of why i'm sitting at
this table and what i think needs to
happen to prevent abortion from
occurring it's it's more of a personal
thing and i think my personal stance on
it isn't as valid as a lot of the points
i'll make later in the conversation
but to understand you better here and i
agree that there's a whole world of
discussion around making life better for
humans and i want to have that i mean
that's an incredibly important
discussion how do we make society better
have healthier relationships but we are
living in a society right now where
there are around 800 000 children in
utero who are killed every day or by
illegal by legal abortion legal abortion
and so it's the leading cause of death
for children it's the leading cause of
death for
people in the united states it's a
leading cause of death that beats out
cancer it beats out any other cause of
death is abortion so that's why i'm here
that's why
children is gun violence i mean that
again goes into like personhood and
language you're it's the leading cause
of death for
i mean abortion is just abortion to me
it's like a completely separate thing if
we're talking about the leading causes
of death in society for children it's
gone up and gun violence right now so
gun violence is a tremendous problem and
there's about seven thousand children
six to seven killed every year because
of guns in this country there's eight
hundred thousand children killed every
year because of
abortions there's 400 000 kids in foster
care so it all deserves our attention
but yeah i think what you're saying is
you're saying my understanding of what
you're saying please correct me if i'm
wrong is that you don't want to define
when that a child in the womb is a
person except unless they're 21 weeks
old is that correct so they they don't
get legal protection and a moral status
until they are 21 weeks and that sounds
very arbitrary to me it sounds it
doesn't sound scientific it doesn't
sound fair it doesn't sound just and you
know my understanding of your position
is you're about nuance and the gray area
but you're drawing a very black and
white line
in an arbitrary place and saying because
of that line a child at 19 weeks
can be live dismembered in an abortion
and you don't consider that violence and
you don't consider that 19 week old baby
even a person and my physician is saying
i don't think that's loving or just
it's not an arbitrary number it's the
the place of viability and why why is
viability though
because it's when a
baby can live outside of the
womb the uterus without the mother's aid
and it matters because
forcing birth on people children as
young as 10 years old a child bearing
age and perhaps also rape and incest
victims which we can get into that too
because there's even um women who have
been raped or have experienced incest
that we're happy to have their children
so there's like nuance in all of these
and no one wants to be used as the
example of why we should be
making these really hard decisions as a
society it's just
the black and white that i feel you are
trying to bring me into is
this personhood thing which is
it is not right based on when or how i
decide when a personhood
is applicable to the fetus
whereas
sorry i keep getting lost
no it's all good yeah it's just it's the
hardest question to start with i think
maybe because you care so much about
these
okay like really the way that i would
frame this is by saying that this moment
right here to me
is
a waste of time and i don't mean to say
that in any degrading way to anyone
sitting at this table or anyone who
believes in the importance of the
validity of trying to figure out when
life begins or when we're honoring that
but
for me it becomes almost irrelevant
because of all of the other issues that
are piled on top of this where
i see so many people in the
anti-abortion camp
voting against it acting against things
that would make this place more viable
for life so if we talk about okay i
believe that life begins a conception
which biblically life begins at first
breath
according to like at least four bible
verses that is something and god also
orders an abortion the bible
but even that i would not want to hang
my hat on the bible to even inform this
conversation because these are all like
moralistic moralistic ideas they're not
actual actually provable they cannot be
concrete
it's a matter of your own personal
morality and your opinion
so with all of that being said
if you believe that life begins at
conception then i want to see what you
are doing to make sure that no one has
to have an abortion that they didn't
want to have because of poverty because
of all these other issues that are
happening and that personal moral stance
in that case is not as valid to me
because it doesn't actually answer any
of the questions that are going to help
us decrease abortion numbers or even
eradicate it if that's your dream
so i think we have to keep going i think
we have to get into that conversation
about how we
help women who are being coerced and
support women who are in low income
situations or abusive relationships to
make sure that they are not coerced into
abortion i think abortion and coercion
go hand in hand and a lot of the work of
the pro-life movement i'm not sure how
familiar with it but is supporting women
who are in difficult situations so that
they are empowered to not turn to
violence and not have to have an
abortion but choose life and protect
their children provide them financial
material care you know thousands of
pregnancy resource centers providing
that financial material care
supporting women giving them the help
that they need connecting them to the
resources that they deserve that's all
very crucial
but i do think it's essential to
establish
a starting point here because the
reality is we're living in a society
where abortion is legal where there are
800 000 children killed by abortion i
know you don't like calling them
children but they're human beings like
you and me and they are just younger and
totally defenseless so it's this
ultimate ageism or might makes right
that the more powerful the born people
are deciding the fate of these pre-born
people and so you don't like calling
them persons i i know as well as from
what you've said so i do think i would
like to understand your position
when you're saying personhood only
starts at 21 weeks because of viability
if if i understand you're saying my
position is that
you cannot you can take a personhood
label and put it on a human or take it
off and the history of human rights
abuses have been when human beings have
been called less than human they've been
called you're not a person you're a
non-person because you're jewish you're
a non-person because you're a person of
color you're a non-person because you're
you have a disability that's the history
of human rights abusers and so i say if
you're a human you are a person there's
not a question of
separating the two to be human is enough
and the science is conclusive it's not a
matter of my religious belief or faith
or some other personal preference i have
or you might have the science is
conclusive when human life begins
and a unique individual human life
begins at the moment of fertilization
well people don't actually agree on the
language of when life begins like
even the language is also complicated as
well
i'm gonna let you wrap this up and i'm
gonna move on to the next question for
lila so go ahead and wrap up your
response to her if you have anything to
say
i mean yeah and i think i've already
pretty much said it which is that like i
i know people want to harp in this one
thing but all i see is like people
running on mouse wheels with it because
you can convince
anyone that life begins a conception but
if you look even at the numbers of
christian people or people that have a
religious affiliation who also get
abortions it's clear that just having
that belief inside of yourself doesn't
necessarily equate to the prevention of
abortion or choosing not to have an
abortion because
of all of the myriad of issues that
we're going to get into
okay great all right so the next
question this one's going to be directed
to lyla is it immoral to force teens and
women to give birth against their will
what about bodily autonomy i'm
completely in support of bodily autonomy
the idea and i think it's a truth that
we need we have a the right to our
bodies in the sense that the possession
of them and nobody has the right to harm
us or hurt us
and we have the responsibility along
with that right to not harm or hurt
somebody else and so in the case of a
woman who is pregnant or a very young
woman who is pregnant she's pregnant
with another is that another human life
is that another small
little human being in there and it is
the science is very clear this is not
something we can kind of create nuance
where there's not it's crystal clear
when there's an abortion it's being done
to destroy it's designed to destroy that
embryo or that developing child because
if it doesn't do that the pregnancy will
continue and the child may be carried to
terms so the abortion is designed to end
a life that's what abortionists do they
they end a heartbeat that's how they
know the abortion has been completed
they have to take
the body parts this is graphic but take
the body parts after the abortion
procedure to confirm that they have all
the body parts removed of that
developing baby and then they know it's
done or if the body parts aren't there
maybe it's not done and there are
actually missed abortions where
sometimes a woman can go in for an
abortion and they don't complete the
abortion and she still has a heartbeat
afterwards that baby is still alive so
she has to go back to get the abortion
completed the job of the abortionist is
to kill so back to the question that you
ask ellen
reproduction has already taken place in
a pregnancy there are two people and
both deserve care and support and that
is the pro-life position
okay brenda
we're brought to you today by buffy i
can say without a doubt that buffy
enhances my sleep and every time a
friend or guest lays down in these
sheets and comforter because i also have
them set up in arahana they are blown
away how soft and cozy it is buffy is
dedicated to making a positive impact on
not only our sleep but also the
environment using only renewable and
recycled materials which makes them as
soft on the planet as they are on your
bed the cloud comforter is covered in
ultra breathable eucalyptus fabric which
uses 10 times less water than cotton to
grow and its fiber is produced using
recyclable earth-friendly solvents
eucalyptus also naturally soothes the
skin for an incredible relaxing night's
sleep the best part for me though is
that the average down comforter harms 12
geese but buffy's comforter is cruelty
free using 100 recycled water bottles
that are transformed and given a second
life as super fluffy fiber it feels even
softer than down while keeping
approximately 50 bottles out of
landfills and oceans this comforter has
over 18 thousand five star reviews and
keeps you at the perfect temperature so
you feel cozy without overheating it's
hypoallergenic and machine washable
thanks to an innovative stitching
pattern that keeps its fluffy fill in
place so use my code ellen for twenty
dollars off orders over eighty dollars
you can try a comforter in your own bed
for free if you don't love it return it
at no cost
i disagree that
providers who provide abortion are there
to kill i believe they are there to
provide a service that will
afford the pregnant person the bodily
god-given autonomy that they have
i
am always
really off put and i feel that it is
almost egregious or maybe my side just
doesn't go to the same behavior and
that's what i don't like
seeing all of these violent images and
the violent descriptors of how it goes
down are purposely used to incite people
into
fear and into sadness and sorrow and
heartbreak depression whatever those
images will elicit in you
i have not seen
anyone showing photos of all of the
children that are killed to gun violence
like i was listening to
an npr episode the other day with a
interview with doctors that
are in surgery after these mass
shootings and describing the difference
between the bullets in a young person's
body with a 22 caliber versus an assault
rifle and how impossible it is to save
them and one of the surgeons said
if we would just release these photos
this whole discussion would end
so in a way i'm like well what a
powerful thing to show you're showing
the violence of it but there is so much
additional violence because
when we look at all of these stories
from not so long ago in the 70s and
they're still happening all over the
world today in el salvador for example
suicide is the number one cause of death
for pregnant teenagers
and throughout the 70s and throughout
all of time in
the u.s when people were having
difficulty getting legal abortions they
were committing violent acts against
their own bodies to make that happen
coat hangers
drinking
substances that would like poison them
they made their their themselves
uninfertile in those cases they bled out
in hotel rooms
there is so much violence around this
debate that is not only the fetuses and
this is the thing that really rubs me
the wrong way these are the issues and
like i wish this wasn't political but it
is because there are people on the
republican side
their values of saving life and
protecting life and preserving it when
we have all the statistics and all the
information to show how to make this
place hospitable to life how to prevent
abortions they don't go for that they're
constantly legislating against
comprehensive sex ed they're constantly
fighting to keep assault rifles in
people's hands and no one on my camp is
talking or showing displays or holding
posters of the atrocious violence
that women endure pregnant people endure
when they are giving themselves an
unsafe abortion
okay go ahead and wrap it up and i'll
okay i'll respond so all of that said
like
i want you to consider
what kind of desperation would drive a
teenager to commit suicide in lieu of
having a baby what sort of desperation
would cause someone to drink poison to
risk their own life
and coercion usually brenda which is why
which is again
violence to solve violence only
continues a circle of violence abusive
situations abusive parents abusive
voices really the only reason women get
abortions i was well you're into an
abortion but it was still an autonomous
choice that i made it really was so
that's not the only way people have
abortions or reason for it so i want to
respond to a number of things that you
said because there's there's a lot in
there and
i think
we have to i think take one piece at a
time to really find can we you know
present resolve one piece at a time and
so one of the things that you said was
that
showing images of children killed by
abortion because i was describing how
abortions actually take place and you're
saying showing images of abortion is
violence
and if i understood you correctly and i
was showing those violent images
yeah so
it's very hard to understand how you can
say that the image is violent but the
act is not violent how you can say that
it's worse for someone to have to
grapple with
the fact that abortion is violence and
that the child had to endure that
violence
because that is a child that was torn
apart that should have had the chance to
live
and that's why that's why i'm pro-life
that's why i'm here and so we can spend
a lot of time circling the wagons and
say well what about you know poor poor
me i'm an adult to survive birth i'm i'm
living i'm in this world and i have to
put up with learning about how babies
are killed in abortion
not poor us we have a responsibility
then to do something to to lower the
abortion right to help those children
and to help their mothers so that's one
thing and then you know there are a lot
of other things in there you started
talking about comprehensive sex
education you said well why can't we
i think that your comment was um we
should be talking more about that or
talking about solutions and i agree we
those are all things to be discussing
but
as long as we are
actively as a society not just
legalizing
abortionists to go out there and profit
from killing children dismembering them
suctioning them to death having them
poisoned to death and as long as it's
even being paid for by the state in many
cases like here in california
that's that's the bloodshed that's the
biggest human rights abuse in our
society today so we need more voices on
that we need more people fighting that
and until we can agree to finally stop
that violence it's going to be hard to
make the progress we need to make on the
other issues we are making that progress
i mean live action is for child tax
credit and working to support pregnancy
resource centers get them more of the
support that they need so that they can
help more families but there's bloodshed
happening today in our cities and we
need to come together to stop that
so brenda i want you to reply to that
and then after that can you address a
little bit more clearly if it is morally
conflicting to have this view
that you said that you're talking about
with you know babies and their inherent
human rights but then also
if there's anything morally conflicting
about forcing women to give birth
against her well but go ahead and answer
her first and then maybe you can address
that a little bit more
i just feel like you just skirted so
much which is frustrating and also
what did i expect
i'm sorry if it was misperceived but i
am not saying poor me i don't want to be
assaulted by those images
i'm saying well you're saying that we
shouldn't show those images because it's
not going to say that okay i was saying
that
your camp is
always putting out those images do you
think that's wrong to share the truth
about what abortion does to that baby i
feel neutral about it to be honest i i i
think because it didn't seem neutral
just a few moments ago well the point
that i'm trying to make is that those
images are accessible and they're one of
the main tools being used to scare
people out of abortion there's also a
lot of inciting description in language
that is not always based in fact and
reality
what's an example
the idea that doctors are going in and
dismembering the body that's how a
second trimester abortion takes place
they are it's like disconnected with uh
not in many cases now planned parenthood
doesn't use dejoction in most of their
abortions
i mean i had a planned parenthood
abortion so i would you have a second
trimester of planned parenthood
planned parenthood in their second
trimester abortions typically does not
use digoxin they do not do an injection
first so whether they use suction
they'll use a suction instrument to help
with the process of the dismemberment
process of the baby and you know we
actually have a series out that's
narrated by former abortionists so that
they've actually done these procedures
they're experts and they describe what
happens in a dna second trimester
abortion well this is where you and i
would find common ground
i mean not really because you'll be
anti-abortion exclusively but for me i
am not
i think the position being taken that
there's some like evil nefarious group
of people that just like loves killing
babies and they're being dismembered in
these violent ways
so
these ideas that there's just like that
that would be evil honestly and the way
that we can like agree or like get on
the same page is to say that if these
procedures are being done they do need
to be done with absolute care and to
make sure that it's causing the least
amount of pain as possible i don't i
don't want to see abortions be violent
in that way and i don't know enough
about that i'm also not like i favor
planned parenthood because they're one
of the only nations or the only not
options in our nation for women to get
the care that they need in a lot of
cases
especially when you don't have health
care and all that all that stuff so
i am
just
saying that
when you are
showing these images
that fine we can agree they're violent i
can agree with you that these procedures
are not being done well in some cases
like if you give me that information i
read it and i see it and i talk to
people i'm always receptive to that so i
don't think that's right so just to
understand you're okay with an abortion
like in a live dismemberment abortion
you would be okay
to dismember that baby provided it was
injected into the heart with a substance
that is actually used for lethal
lethal injections and execution state
executions you would be okay with
injecting that piercing that baby's
soft body tissue into the heart with a
with a substance that stops it his or
her heart and then after the heart
hopefully has stopped beating then it's
okay to start the dismemberment process
that's okay with you but it's not okay
if the injection hasn't been done first
is that what you're saying yeah i think
that sounds like the more humane way so
are you opposed to the death penalty
yes for them
how can you be how can you support that
when how can you support giving
a lethal injection to a developing baby
when you're opposed to giving it to even
a a you know a prisoner who's been tried
in a court of law for
heinous crimes
because this goes back to the question
that i felt was skirted which is that
the violent images that aren't being
shown are
babies riddled with assault rifle
bullets or
i'm opposed to that brenda i don't know
if you already think of my position but
i think that it's horrific the violence
against school children and children in
our country and what guns are used for i
think it is horrific it's mind-numbingly
horrific so we agree on that i'm talking
about
the baby that you just said you are okay
with being killed in the second
trimester as long as its
body is pierced with a needle and its
heart is injected with a substance that
gives us a heart attack and then it's
okay to dismember that baby and remove
the baby from the mother i'm trying to
understand i'm trying to understand how
you're okay with that because of the
circumstances because of humanity
because of my care and love for the
people that are in that circumstance but
you're against it for um you would be
against that for a convicted murderer of
let's say dozens of school children
let's say it's a school shooter who's on
death row and you would say save his
life because it's clear that violence
against him is wrong but because you're
saying there's all this complexity now
for this baby who's developing and don't
save their life well this brings us back
to square one the question that i found
so complicated because it's true we see
we see the beginning of life differently
i believe spirit at conception i believe
life at birth and i believe that it is
humane to have a certain cap at how long
you can go which is when a baby is
viable around 20 20 21 22 weeks i
believe abortion should be easily
accessible so that pregnant people can
make that decision as early as possible
not have to travel hundreds of miles fly
through planes jump through hoops to get
the care that they need and that that
would help that process move along more
quickly
and also
again what's being skirted is are you
morally okay with forcing the birth of
children from children or people who
have had atrocious acts committed to
their own bodies
europe you've been pregnant i've been
pregnant i am more vehemently
pro-reproductive rights than i ever have
been after having an abortion and having
a child it hasn't made me more on the
other side and the reason is because i
implicitly understand and have
experience the toll that that takes on
your body emotionally relationally
everything that is required for you to
take excellent care of that child from
beginning to end
and when people are not capable of that
are not willing to do it for whatever
reason
are in a society that is not hospitable
to new life like ours
then
it becomes a matter of why are those
women dying in the hotel rooms you
really quickly went to oh they're all
being abused i think that's really
minimizing pregnant people are very
capable of making their own autonomous
choices and they don't have to be abused
into it that is not the only instance in
which somebody if it's
your but i'm i'm trying to follow your
argument here because you're saying if
it's a 10 year old or a 12 year old
you're you're saying you're accusing me
of forcing children to have children and
i want to respond to that but now you're
saying
you're not talking about abuse but in
that situation there was clearly abuse
because any 12 year old who's pregnant
or 10 year old there's abuse there that
child was sexually abused that's why
they're pregnant yeah so so but i i want
to very much respond to your points
brenda i'm trying to track you know
track this i know we're all doing this
together um ellen but uh there are two
key things that you said that i want to
respond to the last thing you said about
forcing children to have children and
then you said something else about um
before that we were talking about the
lethal injections for the child and you
were saying that um
uh they're not persons so we just define
life differently said i believe life you
believe life begins at a different time
than i believe and what i'm trying to
say what i'm saying is
it's not a question of our belief when
human life begins that's a scientific
fact it begins at fertilization you can
open any biology textbook and it will
tell you when a unique individual human
life begins now you're adding an
additional layer of qualification
personhood you're saying well that's a
philosophy i think is what you're saying
you're saying well that's a
philosophical question so the science
might be clear when your human life
begins but it's not clear
philosophically when personhood begins
and so you're saying it might be a human
human life but it's not a person yet is
that am i representing you correctly
because it's clear when you're pregnant
you're pregnant with something what are
you pregnant with
yeah a spirit um so now it's a spirit
well these are again like i really but
are you okay with killing a spirit then
i believe that energy moves i don't
think you can kill a spirit when you're
pregnant what are you pregnant with
biologically speaking
i am going to
honestly veto this question and not
because i don't want to give you the
respect or dignity of answering this is
foundational to the entire conversation
we're having point that i'm making is
that to me it is not foundational and i
know that sounds like
a counter to everything that everyone
says but that is why i'm so impassioned
about getting my voice
into this
this muck and mire of the abortion
debate because i am sitting here at this
table with you because i i hate abortion
personally
why do you hate it because i think it
happens very unnecessarily in many cases
because of poverty because of a lack of
education because but why is it bad that
it happens in those cases
because everyone should have a right to
live the life that makes them most happy
and putting the child in the womb or
you're who are you referring to when you
say no i would i mean if you want a
really concise clear answer i will say
yes i prioritize the life and autonomy
of the pregnant person over the
in any case for any reason
up until a certain point of violence and
your point is and and your choice for
viability which i think it comes back to
so you say you won't say when human life
begins although science is clear on that
but you're saying that it's any abortion
for any reason is okay
up until
what exact
marker i guess 21 weeks or so okay and i
would love for that but at 20 down but
20 weeks
it doesn't matter how the baby's killed
it doesn't matter what happens that baby
at 20 weeks is not i already told you i
it has to be done in a humane why why if
it's not if it's not a person if it's
not a human life even as you say why
does it matter because we're all human
beings whereas but you just said it's
not a human being okay so i'm trying to
understand but you know what i do want
to say the next question is actually
more related to the specific thing but
before we move on can you dress
my first question which you did kind of
address but brenda felt like you kind of
skirted and it would be nice to just
answer a little bit more clearly about
like is it morally conflicting though to
have that you know to have this view of
like personhood and the value of baby of
a baby in a womb but what about like her
example of like a 12 year old child who
is pregnant like does that feel more
like conflicting to like force that
that child to give birth i think that in
that case there's seriously likely abuse
or incest
sexual abuse certainly if not incest in
that situation and
the solution to rape or incest is not to
add
homicide it's not to add violence
against another innocent third party
which is the child as you say of that
child they're both children so to kill
one child who's innocent
is not the solution it's not just it's
not loving and it's adding the trauma of
abortion
to that girl
i mean you you speak about birth as if
it's this really horrible hard thing it
can be very hard i mean it can be
excruciating right it is excruciating um
you speak about it as a you know in this
negative way abortion is the first is
the forced birth of a dead child that's
what an abortion is you're forcing early
delivery of a child that's been killed
and so you know when we're talking about
what's best for women
abortion is never best for women
including a survivor of sexual trauma
because it's adding trauma
it's adding a wrong on top of the first
wrong that she endured and i think it's
a it's a reflection on the poverty of
our society's care
for those that are survivors of sexual
violence to send them off to abortion
clinics as a solution to the pain the
first
pain and the first injustice that they
endured
i would say that
i have noticed that there are some
abortion providers who
do
too quickly push people into
like just reiterating like you're here
to make this choice you've already made
it let's go i was actually treated with
a lot of tender loving care when i had
an abortion at planned parenthood
it took like nine hours and i was asked
many many times and brought into many
different rooms if i was abused if i was
coerced all of these things but
i
um i keep losing my train of thought on
the things you just said um
gosh i'm so sorry no it's all good um
[Music]
there was a certain can you remind me of
some of the last things we were just
talking about um abortion as in cases of
rape and incest and
i'm very sorry about for your abortion i
know you mentioned earlier it was
connected to coercion as well for you
it's a double
double plan and i'm i'm sorry for loss
of your baby and i'm sorry for what you
endured in that relationship and it's
okay because it was a very expansive
experience and it taught me a lot about
abortion and pregnancy and life like
having had both those experiences this
has elevated my compassion and my
ability to empathize and understand what
other people are going through
so
i'm like
kind of feeling embarrassed that i'm
flubbing so many of my words but a lot
of it is because the terminology in so
many ways has been so disagreeable and
is intentionally inflammatory or
intentionally
bolstered up
not in my on my side i'm not intention
but i'd ask you if you disagree with
terminology that i'm using i would
encourage you to tell me what you
disagree with and we can discuss whether
or not that's appropriate terminology
because for example if you have some
outlier examples of babies that are
dismembered before they that's not have
a suction birth that's not an outlier
brenda that's how
second trimester abortions are done in
this country
i mean i'm not educated enough on it in
that case but like i said i do agree and
and in fact in suction first trimester
abortions often the baby is dismembered
during that process because of the power
of the suction so it happens in many
first trimester abortions as well
sometimes the cannula which is the
suction
machine that's used the insert on the
suction machine the baby is small enough
to fit entirely through the cannula so
it's ripped from the mother's womb whole
but sometimes it's a little too
developed and will be torn apart in the
process which is why they usually put a
sharp edge on the corner of the cannula
in the process of destroying that first
trimester baby again
i know it's
no i'm just saying again yes yes i agree
it's like no matter what language i feel
comfortable using or not and a lot of it
is me policing some of my own language
because i don't want to disappoint
people who have worked really hard in
the um
the justice of reproductive health to
really choose carefully the words and
the language that best serve what we're
trying to say and i admittedly have not
educated myself on that enough because i
come from an era where just like
pro-life pro-choice this is what it
means so this is all new for me and all
i have is my lived experience and what i
have learned from talking to other
people and the thing that is really
upsetting to me that i just cannot ever
get over drives me crazy bang my head
against a wall is that i still feel you
and i are going in a circle and not
getting anywhere when we're talking
about this because i asked you
but what about the violence
of what women and pregnant people have
done to them they've been failed by the
people around them they need support and
love if they're facing a mental health
breakdown the solution is not to go
commit violence against the unborn child
we're also brought to you today by anema
mundi herbals an apothecary shop
specializing in high potency elixirs
medicinal mushrooms and collagen
boosters owned and operated by a master
herbalist from costa rica their project
educates and supports true fair trade
practices beyond organic farming
education and small farmers to create
remedies that benefit people from all
walks of life i'm obsessed with their
happiness powder which is an energizing
and mood boosting herbal coffee that is
caffeine free and adaptogenic i like it
served warm with plant milk and maple
syrup and it contains key herbal allies
that we like to call happy herbs other
immunity boosters in their shop include
black elderberry syrup mushroom mocha
milk and spirulina an organic protein
rich mineralizer that tastes delicious
in banana mango smoothies but my
favorite items in their shop tend to my
feminine and pregnant body halogen
booster face oil womb tea which is
perfect for pregnancy
and a rose body oil which is just divine
anema mundi uses eco-friendly packaging
in recyclable glass or biodegradable
bags i got an awesome discount code for
you guys too so you can enjoy this
wonderful brand use my code ellen15 for
fifteen percent off anything at
anemamoodyherbals.com
that's a n i m a m u n d i h e r b a l s
dot com the solution is to solve the
mental health crisis that the woman is
facing also really really really
minimizing the trauma of sexual assault
i've also been sexually assaulted it is
minimizing in my opinion and a lot of
people's opinion to just say
from a place of like
by perceiving i don't know affluence or
just privilege it is a privileged
position though to sit here and be like
you know if someone if someone sexually
assaults you it's your responsibility
whoever you are no matter what age you
are to make sure that you don't do wrong
now
i mean to be fair she didn't say that
yeah i i i would appreciate you not
taking you know misquoting me here in
this conversation and i also think it's
important to not um
ascribe you know
make assumptions about the other
person's experiences and background
totally i don't think that's fair no i
would also say you know if you are
willing to talk with
sexual abuse survivors who felt they
were forced into abortion i've
interviewed them if you're willing to
talk with sexual abuse survivors who
have chosen to not have an abortion and
are so grateful that they weren't
coerced into it that they didn't
think that they chose it and it was a
good thing for them i encourage i've
talked with them i encourage you to talk
with them so you know in the world of
lived experience and stories there are
endless stories and there are important
stories but what is also important is
right and wrong what's also important is
human rights and so and that's what i
bring this back to is does the is the
life in the womb of life yes
are they human yes do all humans have
human rights
yes
and if we start to arrange our social
solutions to all of the great
complexities of life
around fundamentally respecting human
life and human rights we're going to be
a healthier happier society society
period okay so let's wrap this up you
can respond something and then i'm going
to ask you your next question which is
pretty similar to what we're talking
about but a little more detail so go
ahead um i do apologize i definitely do
not want to make any presumptions but i
will say that i have noticed a great
deal of people from positions of
privilege simply the privilege of not
having been raped and not having that as
your experience to have a strong opinion
about it i truly believe that a person
who is a victim of sexual assault is the
one and only person that should be
making a decision on whether or not they
are going to carry
and have a baby i think it is morally
reprehensible honestly to
not live in that experience and make a
decision and a moral decision on that
it's it's not in our right i believe
and with that said
you're mentioning all of these
experiences about people who are
grateful that they didn't have an
abortion and i completely affirmed that
that is absolutely true i have talked to
a gamut of people but what you are not
identifying in this particular moment is
people who say the opposite i am
grateful that i had an abortion i had an
abortion with an abuser
again the justice system that would have
made it so i would have probably had to
fight my butt off to not have to share
custody with that child the power that
he could have asserted over me if we had
a child together
the fear and concern about whether or
not my child would be safe in his care
all loomed on me because what we're both
agreeing on is this society is not built
in a way that people are going to be
able to bring forth life with complete
confidence and also like on that on your
side of things people so often talk
about but adoption or all of these other
things like if a rape victim doesn't
want to have a baby just put them up for
adoption i don't think they take just i
think there's i mean adoption is a
tremendously
impactful life-changing decision for
everyone so i i don't i would just push
back against a lot of the
characterizations that i think you're
making right my my like yeah
exaggeration or my tone um is really
meant to just like
enliven things and i don't want to do
that because i do want to be specific
about everything
but
i
i have heard though people say at that
willy-nilly like come on just you know
make a tick tock or something just
choose adoption choosing adoption though
means that you are thrusting that child
into a system that is not working there
are always 400 000 kids in the foster
care system every single day so i'm
really excited to talk about that and
we're going to get into that but let's
wrap up these like foundational
questions i have a question for you last
one i asked was for you so this one is
basically a lot of what we were talking
about and your answer has been you know
like in the gray because you're you know
god is great to be in the garage yeah
but um the question is
there is black and white my
understanding of your position just to
make because we're doing foundations
your position is that abortion for any
reason is permissible up until
21 weeks unless medical technology
develops and the baby can get more help
before that to survive is my
understanding
but
up until 21 weeks whatever goes is your
position so this is gonna be my my
question which is basically what is the
time or moment of distinction when a
person deserves basic human rights and
so this question like is it purely based
on age gestational age when a human can
feel pain is it brain waves a heartbeat
is it autonomy or a certain level of
cognition that matters or is it the
moment a person takes their first breath
like you kind of mentioned but then you
also have mentioned that viability
because viability has gotten earlier and
earlier and earlier over decades as you
know um our medical
technology has advanced so does that
mean that it will continue to get
earlier and earlier or can the question
of when human life begins be a personal
question
i think that i think that there are
like really great cases for some like um
i think that
i'm just really like thinking about how
if we made everything more accessible
and it was
easy to make that choice sooner i would
feel really comfortable
diminishing that number to something
even lower you know like 18 weeks or
something
but really for me
this is a really interesting challenge
to be like taken to task on exactly
how i'm defining life and where it
begins and then we'll get into all and
if i can comment on that too i mean it's
because our laws do
and it's because the society's view of
human life will determine our treatment
of human life and so that's why i know
you say well it's you know it's gray i
don't want to get into these
foundational questions but it is the
question it is the question and uh and
once we have that if we can resolve that
um great i mean there's so many many
more things we can go to but you can't
you can't leave it unresolved because
currently the the pro-choice or
pro-abortion side if you want to say it
is in support of abortion
not being limited at any point in
pregnancy is in support of taxpayer
funding for that abortion and is in
support of it across the country and
even the world so they've they've staked
out a claim and we're saying well who's
they there's there's so much nuance on
on both sides well what i'm saying is
the law the law is and the the lobbyist
behind the law but just just speaking
strictly of the law the law in seven
states in our country permitting
abortion through nine months in
california permitting it up until about
24 25 weeks and even after that as long
as the abortionist signs off on it and
they have some reason listed it can
happen until term in california so
i mean that's the reality we're living
in that is the reality we're living and
so the question is are you okay with
that or not
do we think that these are human lives
or not because if they're not human
lives and you can persuade me of that
i'm i will we i'm i'm done you know it's
like i've devoted my life to this
because this is a human rights issue for
our most vulnerable members of our human
family but me challenging and
decidability or when it's like i i get
the impression if i'm not mistaken that
i'm not going to be able to make any
headway with that because you are
convinced that life begins a concept
well i think because you're running into
facts
you're running into scientific facts
that you can't
you can't talk away and the scientific
fact is that we don't choose or believe
when human life begins it begins
biologically at the moment of
fertilization that's what in an in vitro
fertilization clinic they're looking
when they say oh we created you seven
embryos it's that moment of sperm egg
fusion when you have a single cell
zygote come into existence and then the
in vitro you know specialists can tell
the parents that would be parents oh
we've got you seven viable embryos or
whatever they say you know do you want
to implant these it's because these are
individual children of those parents and
they can decide if they're going to
carry them to term right that's the
whole ivf industry in our country
it's it's not it's not it's not even it
should not be a debate but i think it
becomes sort of political in a strange
way and even like a religious thing if
it's saying well it's a debate the
science the science is clear yeah but
the science is also clear that
pregnancy or uh sex can result in
pregnancy exactly but we cannot mandate
that our entire nation wait until they
have a partner that's going to support
them they practice abstinence like you
cannot mandate that sexual activity this
world is too complex our nation is too
complex the problems we have are too
complex so
are you opposed to are you opposed to
child abuse
of course would you say that the
circumstances in which children are
abused or not even abused neglected
which is a form of abuse but in the
circumstances around child neglect are
complex
no well i mean yeah the circumstances
that get people there mental health all
of that and some neglectful parents are
victims themselves of their own
addictions or their own childhood abuse
cycles or other intergenerational
trauma right
yeah so but that child who's still a
victim of neglect still deserves to be
cared for right and and even intervened
in that situation of the neglect that
they're in if it's severe neglect to
protect that child's life right even
though there's complexity all around the
parents and the mother and everything
else
yes
but you're saying that because i agree
with you on friend i agree with you in
complexity we are we're in agreement
there but but what is black and white is
life or death yeah but you are making
something black and white that not
everyone agrees with not everyone
believes that life begins a conception
and you can have science that you
perceive backs that up i do not think
it's as cut and dry i think in our
nation and in our world we have a very
strange avoidance of death and what it
means and i'm a really spiritual person
like i said so i believe in the
spirituality of it i believe you can't
kill
like a spirit or an energy that energy
just moves so there's a lot of
complexity on what i feel happens when
i'm housing an embryo or a fetus inside
of myself i having that experience too i
felt it i felt the presence of something
when i had an abortion i felt the
absence of something
i am not going to sit here and deny that
at all however
i am so frustrated with the muck and
mire that we're in right now because i
just don't see what good it's going to
do like
i
well in texas when they passed the
heartbeat bill it cut the abortion rate
in half
so abortion going to other states
they're fleeing to other places where
they're having children that they don't
want adding to the foster care system
that is already overrun and not working
so you're saying it's better for a
foster care child to not exist
to be it's better for them to be killed
well i am a pro
reproductive rights activist so yes
so you you're saying that a child in
foster care it's better for them to be
dead
not after they're already
alive in order to abort someone they
have to be alive
otherwise you need to abort them
do you i i think but i i mean there was
there was one thing i'm trying to track
here i don't know if you want to keep
going on this route ellen but there was
one other um thing that you said i want
to make sure we we connected on oh you
said everybody you said if everybody
agrees
um you know everybody i think you were
saying everybody has uh different views
on this uh something to that effect and
therefore we can't resolve it we keep
going in circles right is that kind of
what you were saying
well yeah but i'm talking specifically
about
life beginning at conception i actually
do believe that if we could sit down and
have a more nuanced balanced
conversation about when life begins and
what people morally believe is right or
wrong
with abortion that we could actually
come to terms that would be so
beneficial because if you and i could
come to terms somehow some way and be
like you know what 12 weeks
is a good amount of time we both feel
comfortable with that
then
we can i'm never i'll tell you right now
i'll never be comfortable with killing
an innocent human period that's the
thing it's never it's there's no there's
no argument that will justify killing an
innocent i get it but with all due
respect i truly feel and just because
society supports it i mean i think
there's i think that was the direction
of your comment earlier it's like well
it's so great because so many people
support this there have been times in
human history when people have supported
the enslavement of women and children
and men they have supported
the sexual exploitation publicly as part
of almost a state operation of children
there have been empires that have rose
and fall that have committed atrocities
but just because the prevailing notion
might be something that's wrong doesn't
mean it doesn't make it right and i
think that's and and the other thing is
people are changing on this i mean
people are changing on abortion we see
it every day so laws change behavior and
save lives and then public opinion has
changed when people are educated when
they learn about the abortion procedure
when they see this through the lens of
human rights when they understand the
resources that are available for women
especially low-income women or women in
difficult situations people change and
they don't want the violence of abortion
and that that's what i i think is
exciting and that's what we can focus on
i have a question could she be right
that with the texas abortion ban that
people are just fleeing into other
states and so cutting abortion in half
could maybe not be accurate well i think
there will absolutely always be some
people no matter the law that you pass
that will break that law or try to break
the law but there's no evidence that
says that the 50 of children who have
been uh not aborted in texas because of
their abortion ban in in the state are
going out of state like 50 of all those
women are leaving the state there's no
evidence of that whatsoever so i think
we have to look at at the at the
statistics
yeah
i um
i'm just
i'm really frustrated because
i'm i'm really trying to articulate
something and i don't know how to
get it through but
what i'm
wanting to say is that
this
idea of you believe that life begins a
concern i don't believe it brenda it's
not my personal belief i think that's a
no it's not i learned it and okay but
then sixth grade biology look at us this
is mouse wheels it's mouse wheels
because i i don't know why it is
why you're not i mean i think you're not
willing to acknowledge the scientific
reality because it would mean that
abortion would end an end of human life
and you don't want to admit it but i
would encourage you to stop believing
the side of the conversation i'm happy
to say abortion ends a life okay like
well i don't think you should say
anything you don't believe i think you
need to believe it it's it's not that i
don't believe what i just said it's that
i literally honestly honest to god see
no purpose in this line of conversation
this to me is the biggest factor i agree
if you're
this to me is the biggest frustration
when i come to the table because i am
telling you for the umpteenth time i am
here to prevent abortion because i don't
like abortion and i would like for those
numbers to decrease or in some magical
land be completely eradicated not every
person believes the same way that i do
some people in my camp would think
that's a little extreme and they want me
to feel
less moralistic or less emotional about
it but i do and i feel comfortable
sitting in that gray and saying i don't
feel
comfortable with this so what does that
do that propels me into an obsession an
absolute obsession with figuring out how
we make this place hospitable to new
life you and i deciding or arguing about
biology class
it gets us nowhere i don't see this
going anywhere all it's going to do is
have viewers be like lila said all the
right facts and brenda stumbled around
because it doesn't know the proper words
and we've solved nothing except make
both camps feel like nice and tidy that
they're on the right side of things okay
you finish up i wanna i have a perfect
question for you after what you just
said because i do think that you speak
to what a lot of pro-choice people feel
um most
choice people when you ask them why
they're pro-choice they say i wouldn't
personally get an abortion because like
you said i think you're right that a lot
of people who are pro-choice aren't like
championing it championing it
championing it
um
but they say but i personally i wouldn't
want to force or restrict someone else
from ending a pregnant keeping a
pregnancy that they didn't want why is
that not good enough for you that seems
to be a lot of people's stance
and i want to respond to what brenda
just said too so i'll start with what
you just said ellen um
i would say i mean i say is
you can have a personal opposition to
something you know
let's say i'm personally opposed to
child abuse but it would be wrong for
you to say okay but i'm not going to
tell somebody else how to treat their
child some things a lot of some things
well i i think it is a fair comparison
if you acknowledge the science of when
life begins and you acknowledge that
we're talking about a human life
and i think human lives are precious and
they have rights and so you know i think
our personal belief around something um
does matter but we also have to
acknowledge
things that are outside of our personal
beliefs which are both science and moral
law around human rights
you have thoughts i also want to respond
to apprentices okay but i don't know if
you want to know
go for it um and then to your other
point brenda which i think you were you
were sharing about how you want to have
an obsession on making life better for
people which i think is beautiful
i
the the starting point in my book and
the reason that i'm
working to educate every day about what
abortion actually is
connect women to the resources that are
out there is that we cannot have a
culture of life really people flourish
if we literally in our communities have
centers set up where people are killing
pre-born children and and that's that
that is a culture of death by definition
and so other cultures of death in our
society though i agree there's a
necessity for people i agree with you
there's a lot of other i agree with you
i'm gonna push back a little on the
necessity word because i think women are
a lot more uh capable than we give them
credit for a lot of the time and there's
a lot more resources that do exist i
think fear is a big part of a lot of
abortions fear of the future um fear of
the repercussions and so i think part of
it is legitimate
i i i'm not if your child is going into
an abusive foster care system like that
fear
is legitimate it's based on a reality
it's based on a fact if you are a black
woman in louisiana being forced to give
birth and one of they have the number
one highest maternal death rate in our
nation and you think abortion is helping
when more women give birth health
healthfully i mean that
makes sense i think that if you are
hypothetically a black i mean abortion
doesn't improve maternal mortality rates
for for black women yes but i'm talking
about in this
sphere like you can't minimize or say
that i'm not just in fear i know you're
i'm not trying to imply you're
minimizing anything but i'm saying
to just say well people are resilient
and they can actually do better when i
have
a society around me a nation and a party
that claims to be pro-life but does so
many things that actually result in the
opposite like these are not just fears
these are valid valid concerns that are
happening every single day the highest
maternal death rates in this country
happen to be in states that are wanting
to force birth louisiana texas
there's many others jersey they're not
all even just pro-life
so-called states and we're not even
focusing on a maternal death rate
problem or the maternal death rate of
black women so it's not
that abortion has to be a necessity and
i can understand why you push back on
that however if you already have
children which is the majority of people
who seek out abortions and you're
worried about poverty which is valid and
you're seeing your children not be able
to eat and you're seeing all these
systemic problems your kids are getting
shot in school these are not just fears
these are valid concerns that cause
people to say you know what i don't want
to bring a baby into this inhospitable
place where i might
die there it's going to take our entire
nation our unity
um to solve that and that's why i got so
frustrated and i still feel that
frustration inside of me on what i'm
calling the mouse wheel because our
aligning and deciding we agree when life
begins will not also change my stance on
what needs to happen and that abortion
needs to be accessible until we can make
sure those freaking women aren't dying
out there
and i i think we're in agreement that
there is a death culture in our country
a culture that is often very inhabitable
to human flourishing and it's all hands
on deck it's in how we treat each other
it's in how we treat our own families
that we're given or we're born into our
chosen families it's in you know the
communities we're part of and how we're
helping our neighbors there's
a lot there to unpack
but how i i can't it is um
i think impossible to achieve i think
the society you're dreaming of and i
agree i i'm united with you in a society
that's open to human life flourishing
human beings can flourish
while permitting the violent act of
abortion against our youngest and most
vulnerable members and that's why i'm
here i'm here to say i can't give you
that point to say oh it's okay to just
kill them in the room as long as they're
20 weeks not 21 weeks and then we're
going to go out and make life better for
everybody else
i we can't those two things can't hold
together we need to say all life is
precious and set the tone right from the
beginning and then act on that go in
reverse because until this place is
hospitable like every place that so you
prioritizes its citizens prioritizes
comprehensive sex ed from five years old
prioritizes access to birth control
prioritizes not killing its citizens
through gunfire the myriad of things
prioritizes maternal health and making
sure women don't die in birth
the nations that do that have lower
rates of abortion than we do in this
country because
i why why wouldn't you then like then
you would actually have to have another
reason then you would jump to another
thing like to me the true tragedy is
that many people go into those abortion
clinics and they are there out of a
necessity that is not just perceived it
is valid and real
and we are not focusing on how to make
it hospitable for them like i agree with
we'll do that is the abortion clinic
making it hospitable for them i think i
i think this is where i agree but we
also disagree profoundly and that i am
all and most of the work of the public
movement i don't know how familiar you
are with the pro-life movement i know
there's a lot of stereotypes especially
among you know the the pro-choice
abortion side that
likes to think of the perfect movement
in a certain way but the pro-life
movement that i'm a part of is
day in and day out supporting women and
young families and children in
communities through helping getting
involved in the foster care system to
make it better i have many friends
active in fostering organizations active
and fostering to support healthier
outcomes for those kids make life better
for them helping women who are
unexpectedly pregnant help them with the
material resources that they need
helping make adoption as positive as
possible because it is a beautiful thing
it can be very challenging but it can
also be really beautiful there's a lot
there that's beautiful that i'd love to
explore with you but i still cannot see
it and we cannot accept killing a child
as somehow the foundation of this
beautiful culture of life that we want
to build together
maybe the question is like i i again do
you hate that it's political because i
don't like to be divided and that
becomes black and white as well democrat
republican but
i am curious if i could ask a political
affiliation or if there is
anything any relevance in that to you
because
it's not like a misconception that
pro-lifers so-called tend to be in the
republican camp
like donald trump was a pro-lifer
so-called all of that stuff so i'm used
to seeing these people legislating
for
the removal of bodily autonomy the
removal of reproductive rights also
simultaneously
vehemently against comprehensive sex ed
and going on
channels and instigating all of this
fear and fear mongering around they're
gonna teach your kid anal sex at five
years old and all of this stuff to make
people afraid i also know a lot of these
states that are trying to legislate
forced birth are also trying to get rid
of birth control and get rid of access
to women's health in general and again
not even looking or taking care of their
maternal death problems
so
i
think it is important to get into that
because i can respect you very much so
if you tell me look i'm here on the
ground i have this personal belief
system
that i believe is fact that i don't
believe is fact but you know you have
your own belief and you have built your
entire life around that and in doing so
the work that you're doing may be
beautiful and you may be instigating a
lot of beautiful change in society in
the small pockets of people that you
have access to even if it's a lot of
people
the larger question for me then becomes
but what do we do as a larger society
because we're talking about legislation
we're talking about the supreme court
and roe v versus wade so this isn't just
about
like community we don't even have
infrastructure of good community like my
dad taught in inner city philly to
exclusively black and brown students
while i sat in my middle class class
that was exclusively white and the
disparities between the way we have
redlined and treated some communities
and put them on the outskirts which i'm
sure you are incredibly familiar with
with the work that you do
has again made
such a level of inhabitability for
people and such a level of egregious
poverty and pain
that
i just don't see how we can address this
issue without
addressing the fact that these values
that people espouse or seem to have
don't align with making policies that
will statistically provably
decrease abortion rates and help mediate
this problem so before you reply
do you this is like exactly a question i
was going to ask you do you think that
the way we talk about this debate
pro-life and pro-choice is accurate and
descriptive to how people who hold those
views truly think and act it sounds like
you don't think so
because you feel you kind of label like
pro-life as republicans and pro-choice
are democrats and so therefore they
don't you know republican republicans
don't care democrats do care
what do you think yeah and i'm sure you
could already intuit my resistance to
that i don't again being in the gray i
don't ever look at someone and be like
oh you're a republican this means x y z
you're pro level for choice and that
means x y and z and i also think that
that does a great disservice as well
because i think attention grabbing
headlines
do a lot of work that can be so
counterproductive because in getting
someone's attention in a society that
has like an attention deficit and will
only read a headline and they won't get
into the mire of like but wait did this
really help prevent abortion is this
really doing a good service to the
community and the people involved like
and then also having these these ideas
about one side being evil we're baby
killers you
are you know you don't care about life
outside of the womb we all have these
stereotypes of each other and then when
you talk to people on the ground which
you and i both do you find that is not
true that people run the gamut on the
reasons they have abortion the reasons
they don't or wouldn't the reasons they
vote the way that they do but there's so
much
fallacy so many misnomers i mean not
only with the abortion debate but also
just in like women's health in general
like me having what is it called when
you're
old ass pregnancy over 35 you are a i
don't know geriatric pregnancy oh
there's a lot of misnomers in the
medical field that i think we have to
work through and i try my best to honor
all of that said with all of that
complication
i am not at all seeing
an alignment between values and
legislation and i am not at all seeing
an alignment between being quote
pro-life but really like really to the
truest sense of the word pro-life
overturning roe v wade is not pro-life
because it's going to cause so much more
death it's going to cause so much more
heartbreak because these same
legislators won't legislate things that
actually improve the society and make it
again hospitable for life okay lyla i
mean i i disagree i think
there's a lot that you just said so to
try to boil down some of it um
if there are centers in our communities
where there are
doctors who are killing human beings for
profit which is what they do
for money and we don't have health care
we have to pay for it well then the
taxpayers will be paying for but
regardless um
that that's a culture of death so that's
that's
that's violence against the most
vulnerable members of our population so
i know you've said so it's like what
about everything else
but i i want to address that but i think
there's a fundamental there is obviously
a fundamental disagreement you're not
acknowledging them as human beings
they're just sort of maybe you mentioned
spirits or i don't know what's so
important for you to get me there
because i think this is a conversation
about human rights and there is a whole
there is a whole
apparatus
that legally that has succeeded in
removing the human rights of a whole
group of people simply because they're
not born yet
and
that's one of the reasons i agreed to
come here today because i'm advocating
for their right to just exist their
right to be born born into what and and
let's we can talk about the world but
you guys the first right is to be is to
is to live that's the first right okay
so what about all the other stuff that
she said so and all the other things i
think we'd probably agree on a lot i
don't know what you know i think so too
because that's the point i'm always
trying to but i but we can agree on a
lot like i could sit down with someone
and sit down with you and we can agree a
lot about you know women deserve health
care i mean pregnant mothers deserve the
best care that they can we can
provide as a society
like are you a champion of universal
health care i mean i think there's a lot
of disagreements about how we can get
there i think we have to really focus
i'm a big believer of if you want to
talk about the theory here subsidiarity
so making the community as responsible
for each other as possible so the kind
of top down you know at the federal
level push for how communities
individual communities should behave
usually gets into a lot of
trouble and issues but i would say yes
we need to ensure in our communities
that women have health care i think
there's right now a starting place is
making sure that taxpayer dollars are
being rerouted away from abortion to
provide actual prenatal care for mothers
but what about i think that's a that's a
first step but what what fun and i've
advocated for that that um publicly many
times i don't know abortion provided by
our society though you have to pay for
it
that's not completely accurate in many
states abortion is paid for by the state
for low-income women and
planned parenthood is the recipient of
over half a billion dollars in uh
federal tax dollars every single year so
as an immediate public policy solution
i'd say reroute that money to provide
free and comprehensive
prenatal care to amend another no
because killing a human being is not
healthcare and we can keep going in
circles but no because killing a human
being is not healthcare so but caring
for that human being and their mother is
healthcare and i would absolutely
advocate for that well let's talk about
healthcare for a second because again my
experience is that i had a job i was
paying 365 dollars a month for my health
care
when i got pregnant i was going to lose
my job because i was modeling so
can't maintain the normal body
that would be required and my insurance
company quoted me six thousand to one
hundred and twenty thousand dollars for
the entire process of prenatal care post
all of that
which would i wish i had been in touch
with you because i could have connected
you to a doctor who would have done it
for you for free
and that's where was that accessible to
like everybody if if you're if you're
struggling to pay your bills and you're
a pregnant woman i will connect you and
please if someone's listening to this
and this is a if someone's listening to
this and they are considering abortion
because they're struggling to pay
medical bills please contact us we will
connect you with direct payment for your
medical bills so that you
do not have to have an
abortion on your shoulders like so you
just said we should take these problems
on your shoulders though no i mean i
feel like i wish our society took care
of us i wish america was what i believed
that it was going to be when i was
little i think the difference is that
like
one side you don't want to push it to
like both camps extremes like that but
there's differences of opinion on
whether it's the most helpful for the
government to delegate all the tax
dollars and all that all the ways to
help people or if we should have more of
a focus and
an emphasis towards valuing helping us i
think it's a myth
i think it's a mix and i think that we
can't make it all or or one i think
there's um it's complex and different
communities are different but it is a
mix and
i think that we have some social safety
nets but i would
passionately
support and i do and live action does
the networks of support that exist and
are growing for young families
especially low-income families and young
mothers so is that sufficient families
because middle class people have the
those two those two brenda those two
i mean
would that it would that be a sufficient
way to move forward instead of focusing
on like tax dollars doing something like
that because some people disagree that
like tax that tax dollars are spent very
efficiently or wisely and so would
something like a non-profit like this
trying to help women who are suffering
as an example there's
something there's opioid medical clinics
i've served on their advisory board and
we've worked closely with them in the
past and they have been working over the
years aggressively to try to create a
national brand so it's recognizable it's
easy for women to know they exist
because i think what you just said i
didn't know like you didn't know that
there was someone who could have helped
maybe pay those bills if you knew who to
email or who to you know what hotline to
call and that's tragedy you know because
those resources do exist and so you know
one one example of this is oprah medical
clinics which are pro-life clinics
providing prenatal care
care for
health care for women providing also
resources when you've had your baby
financial support
even parenting classes i mean a whole
gamut of support for a woman who might
be in a situation of need or for young
men families it can be for both and
what's so tragic is they've had a
struggle to even get
taxpayer dollars some of which are going
under the same grant fund to planned
parenthood because why they're pro-life
so you know we're in a society where
you're saying well the government needs
to do more the government right now is
blinded our especially our current
administration as by
lethal killing of children as a solution
to problems and so a lot of the the air
in the room and the funding is going
that direction as opposed to going
towards pro-life solutions i mean this
makes me sad because why do we just have
to funnel in one direction or the other
like right it could be both yeah like i
it should be both in my opinion it
should absolutely be both we shouldn't
have to be like taking this little slice
of pie and being like please give it to
us no please give it to us it's just
like women's healthcare pregnant
people's healthcare should be top top
top tier priority again we are not
addressing the maternal death well i
think what she's saying when i said it
could be both i think just to be clear
so we're on the same page we're talking
that it could be tax dollars and it also
could be private organizations helping
right are you for that well for the
record i would like to say this kind of
conversational attitude gets me going
yes i'm like oh now we're going
somewhere like this is meaningful to me
because what it shows is like this is
what i want to talk about well
we protect women who are pregnant how do
we protect people in these circumstances
how do we let them know what funds are
available to them what's the best
governmental program to help make sure
that we are taking care of these people
if we were arguing about that like
what's the best way to save black women
from dying in childbirth i would scream
all day with someone about that if we
were talking about legislation and
solution like
this is meaningful to me this to me is
where we will intersect and actually
start solving these issues okay lila to
kind of address she brought up a great
point about all these specific issues
and you and live action are doing a lot
to help like you're explaining your
specific instances where you're helping
individuals and communities um but since
there was literally there's a lot of
like issues that she brought up you
can't take on the burden of all of it
and like what she's bringing up you know
there was over 600 000 abortions last
year it sounds like you want to ban all
abortions from happening so that would
be 600 000 more kids a lot of them in
poverty and in tough situations so
i the question is what is your plan to
deal with that but that's not fair
because like what you said is like that
can't all be on your shoulders
this is whatever your whole life is
based on well no i wanna start by just
saying and to anyone listening right now
you can be against and proudly be
against lethal violence against a
developing child in the womb and not
feel like you have to go out at the same
time and magically on your own solve
every social ill that we face because we
face many you can be proudly against
lethal violence against children and not
feel like
you can't be against it unless you go
out and solve every social ill in the
world
that said
um the social ills deserve attention the
greatest of which is abortion because
it's the killing of
over 800 000 children a year
our other social ills deserve attention
i don't know if you can follow what i
say online but i i occasionally speak
out against other social ills that i
perceive
and i'm concerned about live action
certainly is involved again in
connecting women to support and
resources our primary focus is education
because i have found that sometimes it
is simply education having awareness of
your own um
the the development of your own
pregnancy the development of that child
the facts about the abortion procedure
that can mean life or death for that
child and the lifestyle education and
the lifelong so just finish and the
lifelong regret of abortion that many
women experience
that simply education on abortion
procedures its risks and the development
of the child can mean life or death for
the child and mean
avoiding a lifetime of pain and regret
for a mother so i think that that is a
fear
i think that's my opinion so you're
saying women don't regret abortions
because i can just introduce you i'm
just saying hundreds of educating people
on
a certain lived experience that not
everybody shares and presenting it as
the thing that happens and also so you
can get to the most extreme cases like
showing aborted fetuses that are later
in term to
like just
it's bringing attention to me to
like inciting things inciting fear
inciting emotion versus to me education
is educating people on
their body their personhood their
consent how to have sexual integrity how
to not rape how to heal from sexual
trauma so that they don't perpetuate
that sexual trauma unto other people
sex education basic fundamental ideas of
how you're getting pregnant these same
states that are trying to enforce birth
also have the highest rates of teen
pregnancy and std because they refuse to
educate their kids on
how you get freaking pregnant and that
leads to so many abortions
so
i
i would just talk about multiple things
that you just said um i think there's
some inaccuracies there but
just on the last thing that you said
which is you started talking about
sexual um sex education
before going to that which is another
topic we can discuss um you started off
you know you were responding just by
saying to tell a woman
about the abortion procedure
you said is somehow i think this is what
you're saying correct me if i'm wrong i
somehow
fear you know instilling fear in them
and i it's baffling to me quite frankly
because i think informed consent even if
you're an abortionist
you know and you should at least your
patient deserves to know what that
abortion procedure is so much
emotionality you're like and this so i
would i would direct you to the resource
we use because the the primary resource
that we use
are
medical professionals former
abortionists explaining the abortion
procedure and medically accurate
depictions of the abortion procedures
and those are the primary vehicle that
we used along with you know story is a
figurehead
so this is the kind of information so
you're saying i can't so
i'm trying to understand so you're
saying that it's wrong to be
passionate against violent act against
children because that would instill fear
in someone no i think it's wrong and
misleading to say that there's only one
experience that people have of abortion
and there's i didn't say that brenda
well okay so i think it's wrong to
present one idea that it's sad that it's
tragic that it causes it is that a child
is it doesn't have a life in front of in
front of him or her but there is a
there's like a medical way to do it in
which you present the facts and people
can there's a medical way to kill
someone nationality about it i mean not
everybody feels the same way yeah we're
not good we're going to keep going in
circus because you're saying well if
it's done in a medical setting and if
it's not done not 21 weeks but at 19 or
15. i mean if you were getting cancer
treatments the doctor came in like
flailing his arms and was really
emotional about it that's not the way
you give people facts and information
about i don't know anyone flailing their
own life so i i'm not saying you as the
figurehead that's the kind of
information education you're giving
people by ex expressing it in that way i
think it's not everyone's shared
experience i think you're
misrepresenting our how we educate okay
so i'm gonna move forward to the next
question um you have this is for you
brenda you have said that you're
pro-choice because of your faith what
faith is that and lila please respond
with your thoughts after you share
really do believe fundamentally that we
have a god-given right to our own
autonomy and
obviously i understand the complication
because a
pregnant person is then carrying
something that could become a life in
this world
but
when i look out in the world
and i
see things through the lens of my
christian faith and when i see things
through the lens of the way jesus
behaved and walked through this world
i see
so many egregious tragedies that can be
prevented
all around me i think it is
exciting that so many people are waking
up to all of these things that they had
no idea about before like for me i
understood poverty and racial disparity
and racism growing up just because i had
a front row to segregation by means of
watching my dad go to a school that he
would never permit me or my brother to
go to because it was dangerous he had
like four or five kids die
throughout every summer and he would
come and sit down with us
september 8th and be like teary-eyed and
be like we lost so-and-so so and so so
and so to gun violence and and hunger
and different things that were happening
only in this community 15 minutes away
from where we lived
so i knew all of that and it really
wasn't until we had all of these social
upsets when we were sitting at home in
our houses really marinating on
everything that happened george floyd
was killed
i personally had so many more awakenings
to what injustices are happening what
kind of
white supremacy this nation is built on
how all of these things burgeoned and
became the issues that they are today
and there are solves to it like when you
looked in the camera and said this isn't
your responsibility
that might not be a quote but it's not
your responsibility i think you said to
to take on the burden of every social
issue no i said you i don't know the
exact quote it's important to get the
question
that's fine you
anyone listening can be proud of being
against
lethal violence against children without
feeling that
they have to solve all of our social
ills before being against lethal
violence against okay yeah so i agree
with that but at the same time i worry
that
complacency trust me the pro-life
movement that i am involved with the
thousands of activists i work with are
anything but complacent
i mean obviously
yes but i mean complacency as far as
the other thing yeah they're looking at
all i invite you to spend some time with
some of us because
day in and day out there's work on the
sidewalks of abortion clinics many of
them to connect and accompany those
women to the life-changing positive
resources and support that they need and
deserve and it can be life-changing and
transformative and i think that's
beautiful i think an individual going
out and doing what they they can in
their own community is great but i bring
up the segregation point too because
there are communities that are in dire
need that are not getting any of the
resources that we have and the onus
being put on each community to take care
of themselves and hold each other's
hands and like walk through these
systems or have to build non-profits
around places just to fix these issues
that i can see easily addressed by
changing our tax laws by changing who is
getting what funds and what's important
to us in the society
our legislators our higher-ups the
supreme court etc are not
properly prioritizing to me the things
that would be aligned with preventing
abortion there are statistical facts on
what prevents abortion like mother
effing sex education and to watch people
continually again and again rally
against that
like that's what i worry about because
when
i don't know what you're referring to
there okay i'm talking about again
looking at the camera moment
because it's my projection of what i can
imagine people
how i can imagine people reacting to it
and that doesn't come from nothing just
being on social media i
have learned how people respond to
things how they receive information and
with something like that i think a lot
of people feel very comfortable being
like i'm a republican because i'm a
christian and because i believe in the
right to life and they'll celebrate
what's happening in louisiana or texas
with abortion thinking great it's going
to get solved and that is the
complacency that i met not your
complacency or the complacency of your
organization but the complacency of
being like great like we have made it
illegal now it's going to be better
there's so much statistical fact to show
that that is not going to get better
that women still do seek abortion even
if it's illegal they've done it in dire
circumstance because
there is not just
fear around this again like i said
earlier they are valid concerns that i
still
haven't seen addressed in the party that
deems itself pro-life and again i don't
know what like political organ or
affiliation you have
but
like can you recognize the disparity in
that can you recognize that in a state
like louisiana if they are against
comprehensive sex ed and they're doing
abstinence-only education that that is
counterproductive to the work that
you're attempting to do i think we can
get into a discussion on what you mean
by comprehensive sex ed and i think that
absolutely
women and girls deserve to be educated
on their fertility on their bodies i
think that and men should too i agree
with that i agree with you um i think
that when it comes to sex education a
lot of it centers around the bio
biological act of sex which i think is
important but i think what's most
important is relationship education for
healthy relationships that's where sex
happens healthy or unhealthy
relationships and that needs to be the
large focus and fortunately a lot of
the comprehensive sex education that you
mentioned that i've looked at especially
coming from groups like planned
parenthood does not do that um it's
actually toxic and promotes uh sexual
behaviors and activities that are
harmful that lead to increased pregnancy
that lead to
psychological emotional problems so we
could get into a conversation on that
planned parenthood prevents so much
pregnancy by giving access to birth
control that i otherwise couldn't afford
if i
because because we have you no universal
health care and also that is not true
i'm a i'm a comprehensive sex educator
myself
and comprehensive sex ed is about
consent it is about learning about the
body it is about understanding
inappropriate touch it's age appropriate
throughout the ages it also is beautiful
because it will help
people not instigate sexual violence
against one another i think again you
want me to be really careful about the
way i
perceive and speak about your movement
please do me the same honor
comprehensive sex ed is mother effing
beautiful and it statistically delays
sex by two years in countries that
actually do this service to their
children and teens because when we have
a fear-based fear-centered education
around sex that is abstinence-only just
weight and doesn't give kids any
information that they actually need to
prevent pregnancy stds
it is exacerbating the problem that you
are trying to solve and this again is
another thing like now i feel like we're
off the mouse wheel can we get off the
mouse wheel and be like can we agree
that comprehensive sex education that is
age-appropriate that does include
relationship and honoring of one another
is something that we should have
nationwide so that the problem that
you're trying to address isn't as
enormous as you're dealing with right
now so you mentioned planned
parenthood's comprehensive sex education
just you know i'm not hanging my hat on
planned parenthood like you didn't love
them you said earlier i think you love
them so i'm i'm trying to understand
what you mean i appreciate what they've
done for me because they were the only
access to women's health that i had when
i needed it when i was living in poverty
myself
they have been the only option and that
is why i support them but i have
conflicts about them so just for the
record like i have no interest in
getting into like a planned parenthood
specific discussion because
they're one of the leading they're one
of the leading educators
um of or promoters of a certain kind of
comprehensive sex education and they
actually have a um
dangerous sexual activity i i can speak
to that if you'd like what planned
parenthood's comprehensive sex education
as they say it
it's very harmful about it so
some of it encourages sexual exploration
you could say among very young children
even
sexual exploration among um
first grade second grade exploring your
genitals you have your own body um well
most girls towards pleasure towards
pleasure to try to encourage basically
the mass masturbation of young children
i mean it encourages your vape no matter
what it encourages i started
masturbating when i was three years old
these are you think it's appropriate to
for a teacher to tell a little
six-year-old how to masturbate you think
that's appropriate they're not teaching
anyone how to masturbate comprehensively
what are they like that added space is
helping people understand we educate
each other on everything school is all
about educating people on different
subjects and the one thing that we're
not giving kids any education on is
their own body their own sexuality
what's fundamentally important to us as
a society
so then it leaves the onus on parents to
do that education which they don't even
have the tools for and the average age
that a child discovers pornography is
eight years old it's horrific
and a lot of the way to skirt that is to
educate this is these are fear and lies
around other comprehensive sex side like
again what is a fear and a lie
that the teachers are showing you like
this is how you touch your voice there
are actual curriculum that there's
actual curriculum that shows images of
young children and encourages them to
masturbate and i can you know we can do
an addendum and i can send you the link
and you put it in the description yeah i
mean i'd be curious to see that that's
not my education i have i'm glad to hear
that but
i can continue to speak to planned
parenthood's comprehensive sex education
as you call it if you'd like to talk
about the issues that i have let's go
into a little bit um and and and as the
proactive i'm a big fan of something
called fertility awareness education
which is really essential to what it
means to be to have your sexual
development happen i mean what's
happening in your body what what does
that mean for as a woman how do you be a
healthier and happier and then on top of
that relationship education which it
sounds like you're
also in agreement with but that can go a
lot of different ways because planned
parenthood says to young teens that you
alone know when you're ready to have sex
that it's not there's not some moral um
uh universe around it that you get to
decide 100
and your decisions are valid as long as
you know you're not being a victim of
sexual violence basically basically
consent is their only moral
value that they place on it and i think
that's incredibly harmful to teenagers
you as a parent and also well but it's
not up to me as a parent if planned
parenthood is in my school promoting
that kind of garbage to
my young children i don't think it's
garbage i think everyone again i'm a big
believer in personal autonomy and i
believe that teenagers and even
pre-teens are much more advanced than we
give them credit for it i agree with
that minimizing a person's ability to
make wise decisions for themselves by
giving them full access to all of the
information that they need about their
body and their sexuality promotes
healthy decision-making naturally and
then when they go home and they can have
additional conversations with their
parents you could add addendums to that
that would
include your religion and your religious
values that might not be taught at
school it's not anti-religion it's not
pro having sex young quite the opposite
it's about giving kids all the
information they need to make wise
informed decisions about their body
i i think this conversation might not go
as far as we would hope it would because
you're using this term comprehensive sex
education
i'm giving concrete examples of what is
included in planned parenthood's version
of course i don't have a problem with
either of those though i have a problem
but the way you're framing it you're
framing it in a moralistic way which is
i'm telling you so if you don't think
there are moral uh
there's morality around sex i think that
everyone's morality around it can be
completely different you as a catholic
are going to have different morality so
you don't do this you don't think that
there are any foundations for morality
around sex anything that the
comprehensive sex said what does that
mean let's let's talk it's consent so so
consent is the morality that is
sufficient for you when it comes to sex
as long as the person
says that they agree to it it's
sufficient no it's incredibly
complicated which is why usually in
other countries and like norway and
sweden they begin at five years old and
do an age-appropriate conversation
throughout their entire education
because it's an evolving conversation
but you just have their understanding of
all but you just said brenda that
everybody gets to decide for themselves
absolutely including children and i'm
trying i didn't say including children i
think we were talking about children
we're talking about
sex education for children
i don't have any problem with either the
two points you just made the way they're
being framed is like more inciting than
i think is necessary
how it how is it
how is it being framed that's not i
guess what's called a well let's figure
out what's a chil what's a child like
what do we because because i guess when
we were talking about you know like a a
child who was pregnant at 10 or 12 like
that's considered a child like you'll
use that word child but right now it
sounds like you don't want to use the
word child if it comes to comprehensive
sex ed at 10 or 12. or do you think
that's a child so what age is no longer
a child
not it but what age what like because
because i think that's why
i think that's where we're getting hung
up or where you two are getting hung out
yeah i wasn't i'm not hung up on that
language i'm very comfortable and
confident saying there are children
there are pre-teens they're yeah okay
there's like yes i'm i'm i'm an expert
so when you make a comment that they get
to decide completely what's right for
them there's they shouldn't have some
morality or some sort of compass for
their behavior imposed on them
i just find that incredible to believe
because certainly you think that there
are certain uh you know rules of
engagement you could say when it comes
to sex and then you mention there is one
there's consent and then i asked you is
was consent the only one is that the
only kind of okay there's no what's
another one
it's well for me i mean i have my own
personal definition but for
comprehension sex education because
you're saying i'm a comprehensive sex
educator you're saying planned
parenthood does it but you don't
necessarily agree with planned
parenthood and then you're saying that
it involves this very
nuanced complex
process and i'm saying
yes children should be educated on their
bodies and that they should be given
relationship education age-appropriate
but i think what we think that looks
like or should look like is very
different so i'm trying to tease out the
differences right now i think what i
hear implied by people that are afraid
of comprehensive sex ed i'm not i don't
know who's afraid here i didn't say well
a lot of people in a lot of but but what
do you mean by comprehensive sex
education because i guarantee you yeah
i'll maybe do this one first because
these are the options that i see
that
you uh women a lot of girls will explore
their body and
start masturbating and orgasming at
three years old we start really young i
actually started three maybe even
earlier i don't remember
and that is very common boys will start
later but again boys are discovering
porn at the age of eight years old are
you okay
are you against that absolutely why why
if you're saying it's okay and kids
should be kind of supportive and
masturbating why do you have a problem
with porn no one because because
well i mean are you against
masturbation i guess is a good question
i think that it is completely
inappropriate for teachers or for
parents not not teachers or for parents
if uh
how to masturbate i think that is child
sexual abuse no one means to learn how
to masturbate you have it intuitively
inside of yourself what they are saying
is that it is okay to explore your body
and your body is for yourself you can't
be touched in certain places what you're
doing is educating children so i think
you're sexualizing children no because a
child who's touching their their body
parts to say that that child is
masturbating and that the parent should
somehow
encourage or come around that child to
allow that child to or not even allow
but teach that child well this is
masturbation why are you saying teach
that child so what would you say what's
the appropriate i have a question though
i have a question for you because could
it be possible that it's helpful to not
shame or put down like like she's saying
when children are not like touching
themselves and then affirm
hold on i think she might be i think she
might be saying more like affirming that
it's like look if that's something you
want to do in the privacy of your home
something you might i don't want to miss
call you but yeah there's a lot of um in
between where it's like it's encouraging
masturbating or not like this is kind of
going off of the discussion but it's
kind of important too because this is
something you really consider helps
prevent abortion in what you call
comprehensive sex adversity what you
call comprehensive sex ed is different
so
let's just finish this up go ahead and
answer a little quick answer and then i
have another question to move on to um i
don't think that in any way children
should be shamed about their bodies
right and i think that they should be
given age-appropriate guidance for their
bodies like if their child says like
what's this and you make up some weird
term for you know that's your vagina
that's your penis i think that's
actually really important to use
okay but what i think is completely
inappropriate yeah
and actually abusive is to take an
innocent three-year-old who might be
exploring their body or just like oh
what's you know what's this and say oh
that's masturbation you can go in your
room and feel around there and then you
might experience something called an
orgasm i think that's completely
inappropriate and abusive and it's
sexualizing a three-year-old okay i
don't know why you're saying it's
sexualizing a three-year-old because
then i was sexualizing myself i think
[ __ ] i think there might be what you're
saying is like encouraging in a way of
like it's called graphic type of yeah
versus absolutely not so that's okay so
that's a fundamental difference here
this to me is like really devastating
that you won't come to the table with me
on this particular issue because if you
if your organization
would do me the great honor and pleasure
of
actually
championing comprehensive sex ed that
you and i still haven't defined it
brenda you can't use you can't use that
you're using because you are saying
things that i completely disagree with
but you just said no one agreed with
planned parenthood doing it that kind of
education so i'm not i'm confused
is not talking about teaching like
you're not guiding kids in masturbation
some of these books are some of their
when they're eight years old and you've
taught them abstinence only and haven't
taught them anything about their body
and they discover porn then they're
gonna know i i'm not advocating for that
so i agree on making sure the children
are safe and protected and not
sexualized the fact of the matter is a
lot of children in this country are
sexually abused and they will be
discovering it way before that they even
should have so you know what
comprehensive sex ed can do is tell you
you know when you discover this it's
pleasureful right that is only for you
that is for you is that if anyone else
is i think you can
you can avoid
um teaching or uh encouraging in some
way a child to explore masturbation and
still
teach them boundaries with adults and
protect them protective mechanisms with
it with adults so to conflate the two i
think is incorrect
well no i'm not conflating them like to
say your private parts are for yourself
you're not to if someone is trying to
touch you there that's inappropriate you
say no you want you might you can do you
can do appropriate protection training
for little children who might be victims
of sexual assault you're showing us it's
not working a lot i don't know that it's
not working as much if it's not some of
it's not working and some of it's just
not being done but planned parenthood is
not the solution because they are
sexualizing children and a lot of their
their practices are
horrible and we've done exposes on them
we've done reports on them and i can
direct people to that i mentioned two
examples earlier
i mean
saying a child is being sexualized
because they are being told to not have
shame when they're exploring their body
in private i didn't say that i i i think
that's yeah you're saying things that
are like really over the top that are
not happening well i don't know if
they're not happening but i do think
this is a really fascinating
conversation on what comprehensive sex
ed is what's optimal can i say one other
quick thing because i do have a
curriculum that i think is fantastic and
that is done by a group called fem um
and they have some amazing um they're
connected to some amazing curriculum
that they're offering that is
age-appropriate um
really focusing not just on your biology
there's some biology to it but when
you're very young it's mostly about your
relationships and your sense of self in
the world so there is and if anyone's
listening as an educator and wants to
know is there a great alternative to say
what planned parenthood is doing
uh what do you mean by absence only like
that it encourages to save sex for
marriage as like the only option
i think that what i would encourage and
what the curriculum later on encourages
when it gets into that is
when you have sex to understand that
this should be in a relationship that is
uh
committed that is um and usually these
are the qualities of a marriage right
religious bias i i don't i don't know
how that's a religious bias marriage
marriage is not a real so i want to move
on because we have other things i do
want to talk about but i do think based
on your sex can create new human life
when you're uh post puberty so what i
what i wish we were gonna come to terms
with though is that if we had
however you want to define it if we had
education in this nation to help
children or help people not get pregnant
and have informed information about
their bodies throughout their entire
life so they were completely comfortable
and assured about the making of the body
the making of a baby then you wouldn't
have the big problem on your hands that
you do well i think there's a
fundamental i think there's a
fundamental disagreement on what the
best comprehensive sex ed is and whether
it should be up to the parents to teach
their child versus
public education it's a fascinating
topic in and of itself could be an
entire episode but i do want to move on
i'm glad we got to talk a little bit
about it though um so let's talk about
some challenging circumstances which is
a lot of the for like uh the
conversation around abortion right like
back to that right even though this is
so important i know that the
comprehensive sex said for sure i know
that this is a big part of like the
conversation that's formed around what
helps prevent unwanted pregnancies and
all that but lila what is your position
on i know you kind of talked about it
but let's like elaborate a little more
and then i have a tough question for um
a circumstance for you
for us
like a hard circumstance for you as well
my first question to you delilah is what
is your position on abortion when it
comes to the horrific instances of rape
or incest or when there's an extreme
health risk to the mother so often a lot
of times when people talk about abortion
it is and like approach being pro-choice
is like well how could you limit that
for women who have extreme health risks
how do you respond to that
rape and ancestor horrific
and
a survivor of sexual violence deserves
all the support and care counseling
support of people around her we need to
be much more aggressive about
prosecuting and holding abusers
accountable because there's a lot of
abuse running rampant in our society and
abusers are not held accountable
if a baby is conceived there's an
innocent third party now there's another
human life there and so the solution to
sexual violence can never be
a
homicide can never be taking out the
penalty for the crime um onto the child
i mean that's this myth of uh
generational sin that your appear
the myth of general
generational sin in the terms of
consequence that because your father was
a rapist then you should bear his
penalty or you should bear a penalty and
be killed for it you don't deserve to
live you're you're less than human so i
think that in that situation they
deserve the care and support they
deserve women deserve survivors deserves
care and support but the solution can
never be to kill that child and what
about the extreme health risk of the
mother um for extreme health risk of the
mother i mean there's a common
misconception in the abortion debate
promoted by the pro-abortion side that
abortions aren't medically necessary
that you need to intentionally end the
life of that child in order to somehow
provide medical care for the mother and
i work with thousands of medical
professionals who say adamantly no we
can care for them both and we should and
if we want to
improve maternity uh maternal mortality
rates if we want to improve um the
condition of pregnant women in this
country we will not turn to
knee-jerk having an abortion in the
pregnancy kill the baby anytime there's
a health issue or crisis we need to work
on addressing what are the underlying
conditions that that woman might have
that is making her pregnancy more
difficult how do we accompany her and
have the right checkups and routines in
place to ensure that we're catching
something in time there's a lot you can
do in the medical process that doctors
do do pro-life doctors to care for both
patients and that's what i would
advocate for okay brenda response i mean
i agree abortions in later pregnancy
are not
i mean they cause so much pain and
strife and heartache and i've heard
those stories and i've talked to those
women and it's
it's truly a horrific thing so yes i
mean i agree our healthcare system and
the way we take care of women and the
babies should be
top priority and
i'm sure that it is in many instances i
i think again there's not like a
nefarious group of people that are just
like super excited about killing babies
there are some people that go to that
more too quickly there are other people
who do absolutely everything they can to
do exactly what you said i think it runs
the gamut humanity runs the gamut but
ultimately i of course agree with
everything you just said so
do you agree then well not with the rape
stuff okay yep so then you can talk
about that go ahead oh just to respond
you've mentioned this a couple times
this nefarious group of people yeah that
doesn't exist that
you know are
maybe enjoy or you know are profiting
from the violence of abortion and
i can tell you that they're i don't know
about the term exactly nefarious but
they're certainly um
very ideologically driven violent uh
practitioners of abortion
one of them who's in behind bars right
now kermit gosnell
because he wasn't he's not behind bars
for killing the child right before birth
but he's behind bars because some of
these babies would be born and this
happens in in late term abortion a child
can survive the abortion attempt because
labor has been induced and before the
abortion has had a chance to complete
the abortion the baby can be born and
kermit gosnell is behind bars because he
not only killed one of the women and of
his patients but he killed multiple
children after birth so there are
abortionists i've been undercover with
some of them our team has been
undercover with some of them who are
practicing in this country legally um
who are laughing about how they
dismember the child who are
talking about how they use their tool
kit to dismember that child talking
about how the child it's like getting
the child run over by a mack truck
during the abortion i mean really
gruesome graphic things this is not some
shock language from a pro-lifer this is
from the words of abortionists
themselves and i encourage people to
look at live actions in human
investigation which is exposing the
actual abortionists themselves in their
own words talking about their abortion
procedures that they're committing
i mean there's no doubt in my mind that
there's a lot of
pardon my french [ __ ] up people in the
world and i
really think
that's atrocious obviously but the issue
is that that's not the majority of
abortions in this country and that's not
ten thousand ten thousand it's not
nothing later i'm never saying that it's
not nothing
more than children that died from guns
and guns as you said is a leading cause
of death but ten thousand children
just well but you consider these two but
hold on you're being a little bit you're
being contradictory here because you
said that uh after 21 weeks you consider
them human lives persons that should
have legal protection and 10 000
abortions annually happen
after 21 weeks in this country so that
you know again
children killed by guns horrific
those children are being dismembered
some of them live dismemberment some of
them lethal injection abortions
but i've i've yet i mean i've instigated
uh conversations on my channel can't you
be against both
well the thing is that i am
against so
later
later
what is it abortions later in pregnancy
for
no reason i guess what i'm trying to say
is
those abortions you know you mentioned
how we need to care about the leading
cause of death for children right and so
i'm just
sharing that that's ten thousand
abortions and that's according to
planned parenthood's research on
themselves group macro and the cdc
that the latest statistics i've seen i
think from 2021 was about 7 000 children
killed by guns also horrific
so the leading cause of death even by
your definition is abortion for children
no because i wouldn't define it that way
and again it's getting into the
irrelevance for me because
it's not that it's irrelevant you can
like
deeply hold that yourself but what i am
saying and i've been saying and i will
continue to say is that
until this place
is welcoming to new life and makes the
yes to have a baby an easy yes and
doesn't have all these obstacles of
going into debt for health care of maybe
dying when you're there because two out
of three maternal deaths could have been
stopped
that is egregious to me it's egregious
to me that people get in such dire
circumstances of poverty or abuse or of
sexual abuse that they
do perform abortions on themselves if
they're not accessible
legally so so would you support banning
abortions i'm i'm confused about your
position because at one point you said
they're children and now they're not
children again would you support banning
abortions after 21 weeks i'm just
laughing not laughing and laughing to
myself because i'm i'm admittedly
telling you that i have not thought a
lot about that terminology and that
lingo and what i know forget the
terminology for a minute do you support
you know you clearly support um
doing whatever we can in public policy
to stop gun deaths of children right do
you support
using law to protect children at 21 and
up weeks from
lethal injections and dismemberment
well i think for me it has to be
necessary and a medical necessity
i what medic what do you mean by that
i mean there's a lot of cases
i also i've like talked to a lot of
people i'm going to also say that i'm
not completely informed about all of the
nuance about what happens beyond 21
weeks but the people that i have talked
to are in great great pain about it it's
not something because it's done because
they know it's a child and it's extreme
and it might actually appreciating for
the conscience and so it's so wrong of
us to say go for it no it's not the
conscious i mean something the
conscience of the person who's having
the abortion it's excruciating for for
many for many women i think
they wanted to keep the baby but it was
medically necessary and if they were
told it was medically necessary and that
is what makes me um so
uh but we were worried about read on
that i already told you i agree on that
so
you do agree that it's that it's not
medically necessary that there isn't an
instance on that because that is
something that a lot of people i think
are very very confusing let's put it
this way let's put it this way in a late
term abortion
um just to keep it very simple here in a
late term abortion
the
child you know you're talking about a
viable baby that you're saying you
support protecting their life i think
that's what you're saying descriptive of
how they die because i already know
i mean i'm going to share that you can
deliver that child via c-section or a
vaginal delivery
and abortion the difference between that
and abortion deliver that child alive
and give that child a fighting chance
and abortion is designed to first kill
that child and then deliver the child so
what i'm trying to say and from the
medical i mean back to the question of
medically necessary in the late term and
it's for the early term too and we can
talk about that more if you'd like but
um
you can let that child live because in
any procedure used to deliver that child
if it's an abortion you're killing the
child first just
let them live let them be born alive
it's there's no there's no medical
necessity to kill the child first where
we see eye to eye is that if there is
not a necessity to do it i don't want it
to be legal i don't want anyone to just
go in and be like i want this late term
abortion it costs twenty thousand
dollars anyway so i don't know who
well the state of california the state
of california will pay for it
um well that's because right now
whatever framework we're in if there's a
dispute on whether or not it's necessary
that again is another really good
conversation we could have that would
actually propel some forward motion
between our movements that i think would
be beneficial because if we do decide
together as a team that there are
circumstances in which it is egregious
and it is not necessary then we could
champion that together and i could agree
with you that that wouldn't be right
whatever that circumstance may be
but the current knowledge that i have is
that
it is considered a medical necessity in
all different kinds if your source is
planned parenthood yes you will i don't
only have one source okay well if your
source is abortion advocates yes they
will probably experienced what medically
necessary what is medically necessary i
admittedly don't know enough about it to
tell you all i do know is that i have
not once spoken to anyone who is like
willy nilly did this because i decided
to it is an incredibly traumatic
difficult decision for people to make
and it is a decision that they feel and
their doctor and their care provider
felt was out of medical necessity
did you know i mean i have a question
two things one so do you think that
doctors are lying to their patients that
they need another mission many are
misleading okay and then two can you
guys get on the same page then based on
the way you're explaining it based on
what it sounds like you might be saying
i'm not totally sure that you both agree
that later at least late term abortion
is never medically necessary that
instead you can induce the baby it's
absolutely not try to take care of that
baby or do you agree that that medicine
is agreeing with that i'm saying i don't
have enough information on it but the
current information i have on it is
not
i would get on the same page with you
and say well then there needs to be more
information and people need to
understand that there is more choice
than one but
if there is more choice than one and if
it isn't medically necessary then
you know either way these people are
going through an excruciating decision
the abortion is very excruciating for
the child as well i mean a doctor should
never be misleading anyone into anything
so i agree with you on that but i don't
i don't know enough about late term
abortion or abortion later in pregnancy
to actually
get into the mire of what that looks
like okay what about um
abortion being considered medically
necessary in the beginning of a
pregnancy because i've you know i've
seen stories where women are saying i
got pregnant i wanted to have this baby
but i had to have an abortion because of
specific medical
issues medical not saying necessarily
just you know the child had a fetal
abnormality or anything like that but
maybe health risk of the mother can you
explain your position on that and let's
see how you feel about that there's any
common ground as just an example um
dr anthony lovatino who's one of the uh
professionals medical professionals that
we work with he was one of the ones who
was behind our first abortion procedure
series you know explaining what happens
during the abortion procedure he worked
at a high-risk
facility in upper new york uh for many
years uh treating tens of thousands of
patients and he said in his entire time
treating high-risk pregnancy so he was a
specialty doctor to go to my clinic to
do that he never had to use abortion
to
resolve the medical emergency or or you
know make them the pregnancy or the
mother healthier in some way so what is
the difference then because like let's
say there was something are you saying
because
it's the way that you do it like if you
uh induce the baby even if they're
before viability you know that child
won't survive that that's not abortion
is that what you're explaining
well i mean you're talking about the
distinction between
care for a pregnant mother in a risk
high-risk pregnancy situation in the
late later terms
in the earlier terms like if we can
acknowledge and agree like you're saying
you're not so sure um but if you ca if
you come to the if you came to the
conclusion that okay yeah late-term
uh pregnancy that if they were told that
you know you we have to abort your baby
because of xyz medically necessary
you're saying instead a deuce the baby
which induce the baby and give that
child a fighting chance which is what
i've seen other doctors
i think they can defer the beginning of
pregnancy if someone is like if there's
a certain situation where there's
something very extreme health risk of
the mother and the baby are you saying
that instead of you know dismembering
the child in the way that you depict
what abortion is instead if you induce
the baby that that's not not abortion
because i think people are really
confused at what the what the difference
is what i think is what you're saying i
think i see what you're saying and i
think often times the very high-risk
stake situations with pregnancy happen
later on in the pregnancy and so that's
typically where this conversation is
landing about these later term
situations in some very rare cases there
might be in like an emergency situation
there might be the need extremely rare
cases and so rare that even this doctor
never saw this case in his clinic right
so we're talking less than one percent
less than probably 0.001 extremely rare
cases where
um labor might need to be induced before
viability and these are extreme cases
and even some doctors probably doctors
you'll talk to say like well if you just
give him a couple more weeks you manage
the pregnancy she's in the hospital
watched her vitals we can make it for
both lives we can still make it for both
lives so you would get pushback from
some doctors on this but in that
situation if it's a game time decision
and that's you know that's not possible
for some reason i think there could be
some um
you know if the goal is not to kill that
child you're not going in there
dismembering that child but you're
inducing an early delivery and hoping
that you can provide care for that child
to live that's not an abortion okay so
that's your question do you agree with
that yeah i mean no it's really
interesting like i need more education
but that's not what's happening i mean
what's happening is they're going in
there and they're killing the child i
mean so that's that's how abortion is
the reason why i think this topic is so
important and brenda you go ahead and
reply is that this is a really common
reason why people are pro-choice because
they say for one what about rare extreme
circumstances horrific instances of rape
and incest for two and then the other
example is you know extreme
circumstances of the health risk of the
mother or
non-viability actually the most
prevalent one is not even those two
because like for example state of
florida um
they have research on how many um of the
abortions are in the cases of rape or
incest it's point two percent oh no i
meant the reasons why people say why
they are pro-choice well not saying the
reasons why abortions happen i think
we're all in agreement of that but just
saying this is why i'm pro-choice
because of what about these
circumstances well a lot of the times
it's i think there's even another
dimension to it which is that um
especially those on the pro-abortion
side are saying we need and then they
use like it's a medically necessary
abortion that language is sometimes used
they're actually not even talking about
a health condition the mom has they're
talking about a fetal abnormality a
disability that the baby might have and
they'll say this this abortion was
medically necessary because my baby they
might not use the word baby but because
the fetus or something has some sort of
um disability okay what are your
thoughts on that
yeah i mean but it's wrong to kill the
baby i mean in that situation i would
say the same thing it's wrong to kill
the baby this it would be like if you're
the doctor that you're talking about
before who saw no instances of abortion
and later term
it was high-risk pregnancy in general so
it's it's largely the later term is when
it becomes higher most high risk so yeah
i mean pregnancy is a risk and it is
it's it's a lot but if he has had that
experience and he has that information
and that education and and he knows how
to
provide a place that those babies can
come out and be viable i think everyone
would be overjoyed to hear that and we
would want that information more
accessible everywhere i don't think
there should ever be
an abortion care provider misleading
someone not doing their due diligence to
make sure that every everything is up to
bar and they aren't pushing someone in a
certain direction like it should be
completely unbiased and based on reality
in fact you said earlier that late term
abortions can be up to twenty thousand
dollars and that's true um
what's the incentive for an abortionist
who's doing like term abortions to say
don't come and have my abortion you
don't need it
i mean the basic ethics of being a human
being and doing right by people i've
talked to
some of these people these providers and
they truly believe they are doing an
important service and you think they're
encouraging the parents in those
situations believe the same thing
because if there is information that
shows that these are not medically
necessary then there would be a lot of
families that would be overjoyed to hear
this like this to me is one of the
biggest like most common misconceptions
that's in this argument that makes
people on my side look so evil to the
other side like oh we're just allowing
this to happen or we're feeling
willy-nilly about this when in fact
if this is one of the most traumatic
events in a person's life and if there's
another option those parents are there
seeking that option they didn't come in
there being like
i'm in the eighth month and i don't want
to do this anymore they're coming in
because they feel there's a reason and
to your point about
like anomalies or things that are um
what i'm what am i looking for
disabilities or anything like that's
also a shame i truly believe that
because there's so little education and
i think the us is getting better at that
even something as sweet as tik tok has
been helping people get more accustomed
to the idea that there are people in our
society that have disabilities and
they're not able bodied but they're
living full and beautiful lives
that to me is like the power of a story
the power of understanding that
that life is valuable
that is something that actually is
really important to me and then again
goes back into the idea of okay then are
we putting them into a society and into
a place where they can thrive in that
body and
that really is the question to me but we
agree here on these little points okay i
i would just have one more question sure
and then i have a question for you i
mean can you acknowledge then
the um
the impact
that legal not just legal abortion but
kind of culturally accepted abortion
like your autonomy you make the decision
it's you know it's your body your choice
that whole mantra ideology uh the impact
that that has on
um
disabled babies getting killed or the
impact that has on
a woman who's being told by a doctor oh
you have to have this abortion when
maybe she didn't maybe she could have
had medical management of the pregnancy
to help her and the baby be carried to
term
what about it do you see that the impact
that when there's legal abortion when
it's being accepted as this is a good
you know good for women or this is you
know can be a great thing for women now
when you get pregnant you do a genetic
test you find out your baby and this is
a friend of mine or not even a genetic
test you do the 20-week scan the baby is
missing his or her arm
and
termination is offered right right then
and there right
yes that's that's i mean that sounds
that's not just that's not just what
they offer that's that's seen as their
job i definitely have friends who have
been um told that their baby might have
down syndrome so you should probably
abort but that's one of those
but that's legal abortion for you that's
the culture of death for you where we
see abortion killing as solution and so
if the baby's sick if there's any issue
with the pregnancy if there's any sort
of problem the woman's facing in her
personal life and that she feels again
fear that's directing her towards the
abortion clinic then that is what she's
affirmed and that's that's that's the
way to go yeah i i completely agree with
you on that i think again that there
needs to be structural things
implemented resources easily accessible
if you have these resources people
should absolutely know who they are
nationwide and doctors should not have
any bias lean towards wanting to perform
abortion or to
especially if someone is coming in or
well maybe exclusively actually if
someone is coming in and saying i don't
necessarily want this my partner is
abusive i'm living in poverty i don't
know how i'm going to pay for this
i would love to live in a world where
that did not lead to an abortion because
there was that support there which is
why i do appreciate this work that
you're doing
but as far
as
choice i still think that
there are so many cases that don't fall
under that category i had an abortion
that was autonomous i am not in pain
about it it's not carrying through my
life like a trauma that's my own
experience i've internalized it in a
very personal way that's meaningful
that's spiritual
and
you and everyone i think has to grant
the fact that people are going to have a
myriad of different feelings about this
and there's just not one thing
and again come to these agreements where
we find them and see what we can do
about them you and i both agree that
doctors should not be pushing this as
the only option but i also would add to
that we also need to make it so our
society is a place where that option
is accessible where we don't have to
experience that fear because that fear
is no longer valid oh my my kid does
have child care like i'm a single mother
who's working i have five years to try
to figure out how the hell to make money
i would love to get another job to
supplement my income so i'm not
struggling as much as i am right now and
i can't
so things like that have made my life so
much harder and put an undue burden on
me as a single mother and we do that in
so many different instances so again
how can we make this world better to
invite that to invite that yes okay so
i'd like to ask another specific like
challenging circumstance on your opinion
on um the topic of sex selective
abortion where for example the parent
chooses to abort the baby girl because
they're specifically wanting a boy what
are your thoughts on that i mean i think
that's insane yeah i would think yeah no
offense but you're crazy but
i think i'm sorry i'm not trying to make
a joke of everything i just like that's
that's but it does happen really yeah
who well 100 million girls have been
killed
um
globally because
and there are rates of sex selective
abortion in parts of the united states
that are as high as in mainland china
because certain communities in the
united states are doing practicing sex
selective abortion i mean that's
devastating that's just misogyny and
patriarchy at work that's that's really
devastating but did you know that
planned parenthood has advocated against
bans on sex selective abortion
well i believe that would be because
they agree that abortion should be
performed no matter what the reason that
you cannot determine what a reason is it
just
but it sounds like you it's your choice
disagree with that
well i i do disagree with that and i
believe that there's obviously roots and
so why do you continue why have you said
multiple times you support planned
parenthood and
i think that's hard for me to understand
that
you think it's completely insane to have
a sex selective abortion or support a
sex selective abortion because that's
like a that's like a headline versus
what is actually happening it's a
reality for some reason the headline
would be
planned parenthood allows for sex
selective abortion that is a captivating
headline it's like oh [ __ ] this is crazy
it's not
no listen i know it's happening but the
real story i believe behind it from my
understanding education is that it's not
sex selective
abortion that they're advocating for
they are simply advocating that you can
have an abortion up to a certain point
for any reason that the the provider
providing that service
is not to ask or make a moral
determination on why you're there if you
are there because you want it they're
there to give it to you with the
addition of
all of the system they have in place
when they brought me room to room to
check in to see what was happening why i
was there like i said i was there for
nine hours i have a short question for
you to answer and then a short question
for you and then we need to get into
something really important which is the
foster care and adoption system okay but
short question for you then if you are
adamantly against sex something like sex
selective abortion meaning there are
certain circumstances where you feel
absolutely that should be like do you
agree that should be illegal then to get
a sex selection of abortion or do you
think it's more just about education and
hoping our society doesn't go in that
direction or is that something that you
think should be illegal short answer
though because i have a question for you
no i don't think it can be made illegal
because then that all of a sudden puts
like moral judgment on all the specifics
when in fact it should just be the
person's choice and and then i find it
tragic i wish that wasn't the case okay
so lila
would making abortion illegal actually
reduce abortions weren't there a lot of
abortions happening before abortion was
illegal where people call back alley
abortions which are more dangerous to
the women getting them some people
actually say that if abortion was made
illegal abortions wouldn't actually go
down
women who die would just go up that's
incorrect um when roe v wade became you
know when judicial not you know seven
men on the supreme court decided
abortion for the whole country abortion
the abortion rate skyrocketed so
absolutely there are there are there
will be abortions that happen even when
it's criminalized uh that's where
societal education has to come into play
because they were illegal so you
wouldn't have known how many abortions
were happening there were a lot of
estimates being done on how many
abortions were happening illegally
because there are doctors who were i
mean it makes sense because the service
suddenly becomes available that people
but there have been studies that have
been done and you know texas is the most
obvious example right now in the most
recent that when you ban abortions and
this makes sense just for human nature
when you um you know 30 years ago when
we had seat belts were not uh required
by law most people didn't use them then
with education and legal changes
behavioral changes happened and that's
the reality for eagles you wouldn't
actually know how many abortions are
occurring because now that we have the
pill as well people can be getting
abortions in texas without them knowing
it and frankly they wouldn't be able
like if it's illegal and you're going to
get prosecuted or your provider is going
to get prosecuted they're going to be
hidden like that i don't think there's
any way to statistically show that
that's true i mean even the guttmacher
institute planned parenthood's research
arm has said that the abortion uh fewer
women get abortions when they're more
expensive as just an example so when you
create a higher
barrier to get an abortion because
they're not legal there's not an
abortion clinic on your street corner
selling abortions right or on your in
the middle of your town selling
abortions
more women will not have abortion more
children will be have their have their
life which leads great into the next
question that's what i would bring up
like so wtf do we do with this excess of
children that have been born to people
that did not want to have them they were
forced to have well that's the question
that we're going to talk about the
foster care system so the foster care
system plays a role in these questions
for sure lila one of the arguments
against ending abortion is that the
foster care system is already
overwhelmed and that forcing women who
are pregnant into motherhood who don't
want to be parents will create more
broken homes and overwhelm the foster
care system even more what are your
thoughts on that
i think
life is worth fighting for and that has
to be our starting point when it comes
to a conversation in foster care so with
that as the starting point and that
includes the life of a foster care kid
and that includes the life of a child
who's in the worst situation of abuse i
wouldn't say oh it's better that you
were not born i would say let's get you
out of that abuse and let's work to work
for healing and work for a better life
for you and i think this is where
societies have to really kick into
action you know there's whole um
pro-life organizations were a big part
and we refer for this um we are not
doing this but this is an example of
love life and their whole focus is let's
wrap our arms around this community
where not only we're going to shut down
this abortion clinic but we're going to
be
everyone in our this is a church thing
everyone in our church is going to be
fostering or adopting and we're going to
be taking responsibility for every
foster care child in our community and i
think that's the model that's the way is
we take responsibility in our
communities for those that are suffering
in our communities and um i think we
also need to have a honest conversation
about adoption um
i think adoption is not just saying oh
adopt no big deal adoption is a huge
deal that's my next question to her so
once you answer that quickly and then i
have a question but one thing on one
thing on a one more thing on adoption
there are right now um some estimates up
to two million couples
because infertility is a raging crisis
and just a lot of people want to adopt
who want to adopt that are not able to
adopt right now they would hope to
invite a newborn into their home and
they're not able to i know so that's
ridiculous
yeah it's ridiculous and and what are we
doing we're killing children instead in
abortion clinics bringing the 400 000
kid in foster care away from those
parents
well they're not all available for
adoption the purpose of the foster care
system is family reunification primarily
if at all possible so the solution to
foster carers and just that will adopt
all those children out um sometimes
because you know the parents in rehab or
there was like a death in the family and
they're trying to find out what family
member can care for for those parents so
it's very complex but a lot of them wind
up their their entire adolescence and
teenage years and
50
of foster kids end up homeless by the
time they're 18. 50
and numerically you're saying that you
would like a world that were inviting a
surplus of 600 000 kids that were not
initially wanted by the pregnant person
which would be 1.2 million within two
years well you're assuming they're i'm
not following the argument because i'm
saying what are you gonna do what what
do we do with the six hundred thousand
because you're talking about one church
taking in all of these kids and doing
what they can how we promote taxpayer
dollars that from the government into
organizations like obreo clinics like
love life like embrace grace that are
doing work to care for
both moms who want to parent and moms
who want to prepare for adoption and we
we we're there on the ground supporting
them and supporting them
the numbers don't add up like i really
genuinely want to understand if 50
of foster kids end up homeless currently
today fifty percent
and they don't have any infrastructure
to support them a lot of them end up on
the streets or you mean after they are
presented
when they've graduated out of the foster
care system there's no safety net for
them they're 18 years old yes and 50 of
them lined up and that's where that's
where we should be as communities
joining and financially supporting
the organizations that are intervening
in those children's lives to help them
have better lives okay so my question
for you brenda then is about how
adoption is and that's what many
pro-life organizations are doing okay
the numbers okay but but here's my
question
with with enough of us working together
life is worth fighting for you won't do
education with me sex education so hi
no no no no no we're not going bad but
we have to have some really important
questions decrease the numbers listen to
me okay so adoption also forms this
conversation brenda infertility like she
said is on the rise and for every baby
given up for adoption at birth there are
dozens of families wanting to adopt that
baby why is adoption not a sufficient
option for those with unplanned
pregnancies or unwanted pregnancies why
can't abortion be banned and create a
more flourishing adoption system where
babies can go to families desiring to
adopt a child because a lot of people
conflate and get confused with the
foster care system and the outright
adoption system because the foster
system is like she said you know meant
for reunification parents who wanted to
keep their babies and um ended up losing
their child due to like drug use or
whatever different circumstance whereas
outright adoption for women who find
themselves pregnant when they aren't
ready to be parents and don't want to be
a parent yet or at all um can give their
baby up for adoption at birth and there
will be dozens of families wanting to
adopt that baby so how is that not or is
that a sufficient option like could that
be the solution or do you absolutely
feel that even just the pregnancy should
be a choice
again the numbers
are just too they're too high to provide
a really good life or even just like a
sufficiently okay life where someone is
fed every day has a as a roof over their
head for six hundred thousand extra
people when we already have 400 000. i
mean right now our population is on the
brink of not even replacing itself so
it's not like we have too many people in
the united states and yeah but it's too
many
people that would be unwanted by their
caregivers someone wants them there are
there are groups and organizations that
are growing every day with volunteers
and financial dollars and i wish our
government would kick in and support
these organizations too that want to
help and are ready to take on the
challenge well yeah i agree with you
there but i also again wish that we
would do our due diligence and prevent
pregnancy and educate from a young age
because then those numbers would be more
manageable i simply i i think that's a
beautiful thought but i think six
hundred thousand surplus of people every
year
is an unmanageable thing when we are not
even remotely managing the people that
are already here living in poverty
etcetera yeah so
sorry i know i feel like we keep going
no that's okay do you have an answer to
that question or do you want me to be
well no i do i do think it's
insufficient i think the foster and uh
adoption systems have to be amended and
that everyone who wants a child should
absolutely have immediate access to one
or very quick access to one because we
do have this issue and that i think if
that was amended
more people would feel comfortable
giving birth because i can completely
understand i myself like when i was
pregnant my dad was like well just give
it up for adoption and i was like to
what my my dad's own um
first wife was in the foster care system
and she was
viciously sexually and physically abused
her whole life so
i'm just like what am i giving my child
over to i'm not to do that to me
it was an act of love but you don't
achieve your child i mean i think
there's a misunderstanding that's pretty
profound that needs to be addressed
which is that
if you're a pregnant woman and you're
considering adoption it's not that you
give your child to the foster care
system you can actually place your child
with a private couple of your choosing
on your terms and there are
organizations that will connect you
they'll literally give you menus of
couples that you can pick from and i
wish someone had talked with you and
counseled you and given you that
opportunity to understand that as your
option
i mean that's that's beautiful and
that's how it should be and i love to
hear that i would love if that was more
prevalent but instead you went to
planned parenthood and they didn't give
you those menus of of those options
because they are an abortion clinic and
that's what again breaks my heart about
our current system that we have abortion
clinics that women are walking into
they're not given their all their
options they're not given access to the
resources that exist for them both to
carry determined parent or or to choose
an adoptive couple you didn't you
weren't offered that brenda and you
deserved that but this is why a
conversation like this is so important
and this is why again earlier i said get
off the mouse wheel because
this again is where actual change can
occur and where we agree like i do think
it is egregious that people aren't given
the list of options easily accessible to
them yeah on the other hand i would also
say being realistic people do know where
to get those options i i would have been
able to navigate and figure out how to
give my child up for adoption that is a
choice i didn't want to make because one
thing that i haven't given proper weight
to yet is
pregnancy pregnancy can absolutely be
beautiful i
hated the i hated it i know you have a
different feeling i love pregnancy no
she's like i love being pregnant just
running around adorable
um i didn't have that feeling but still
it was beautiful and
i love my child obviously etc but
my bladder and uterus fell out because i
didn't have pelvic floor therapy which
is standard in places like france where
women are given aftercare when i had my
baby i lost my insurance a week after i
had him and i couldn't get my postnatal
checkup because all of a sudden i was in
a different demographic and couldn't i
was no longer as valuable now that he
wasn't in my body so i have been witness
to these flaws in our system that again
make pregnancy not this like lying on a
lily pad having a great time experience
that it frankly should and could be if
we actually took care of pregnant people
which the fact is we don't all of the
things that i have illuminated
throughout this conversation show that
and then there's also the additional
toll on the body
forcing someone to carry a child for 10
months because we all know you're
pregnant for 10 not not not my months
is
a huge toll on your spirit your mind
your body all of it to enforce that upon
people who truly don't want it who are
truly saying this goes against my free
will this is something i do not want
also i is something that i believe
causes pain and hardship to the baby we
do so many lessons where it's like you
play classical music and you eat the
right food and you make sure you're
nourishing that body mind body and soul
as you can
and if someone doesn't want that and
you're forcing that they're not going to
get the same tlc in utero and so we
should kill the baby instead
well i think everyone absolutely should
have a right to that autonomy because
yes it is it is no small feat to carry a
child into florida
i would encourage you brenda it sounds
like the organizations that you work
closely with or the people that you're
close with don't seem to
uh
have the care needed you know the
community around the care that is
necessary for pregnant states of america
well i i'm i work closely with you know
the pro-life movement and i would invite
you to join some of our organizations
are working because like us
but be part of the solution
join one of our organizations instead of
planned parenthood which is not offering
prenatal care in the planned parenthood
they're just the only organization i had
access to i'm not well but there was but
i guess what i'm trying to what i'm
saying is planned parenthood is a
national brand that has received over
time billions in taxpayer dollars
they're not they're filling in a gap
that is absolutely they are committing
abortion no one else's but brenda
they're not providing
um in the vast majority of their clinics
prenatal care they're not providing
parenting support they're not providing
financial support for young mothers
they're not providing uh you know
birthing classes they're not controlled
can you respond that they're not a
birthing center
but that's my that's my point my point
is they're pretty healthcare but that's
not just abortion they prevent pregnancy
in enormous numbers 50 of planned
parenthood's patients come into their
facility having been using birth control
and the month that they got pregnant so
the birth control that they're giving
out is failing and women are coming to
their facility to then buy their
abortion because they're pregnant and
what i'm trying to say is they're let's
do an alternate model for women's health
that is not the kill your baby model but
it's the model of let's provide holistic
care so that you're not worrying about
the six thousand dollar bill once you
deliver
that goal but that's what i'm that's
what that's what i work with right now
brenda that's what the prologue movement
is doing learn you know google obria
medical center or look at heartbeat
international care net is affiliations
of centers that are providing care and
connecting women to free prenatal care
and free resources or learn about let
them live which is literally paying
medical bills for women there's a whole
universe of care out there but they're
not getting the attention and they're
not getting the federal tax dollars
because who's getting it planned
parenthood who in the name of women's
health they're claiming to be for
women's health is actually for abortion
well i think we need a system that is
all that holistic care but we're not
going to have it as long as planned
parenthood is the boss because they are
not friends of you know providing all of
the options to women and making sure
that they have all their bills paid
that's not the right thing to provide
all the options either not personally
because i'm one person but i can work
with the networking i mean
that you want if i'm not mistaken
wouldn't provide all women's health care
no they do oprah okay okay because
abortion's not healthy the difference i
think is the whether the government
should be doing this or whether we
should be making small organizations
non-profits and doing it and that can be
done i think there can be a can be a
okay it can involve yes so i have like
five more questions to quickly get to
short answers guys okay so can you
address what she was talking about women
who truly find it traumatic to go
through pregnancy don't want to go
through pregnancy and even this is a
very specific question i wasn't even
going to ask about women who are really
suffering mentally and would struggle
immensely to go through pregnancy like
someone with depression who's on
medication that could affect the baby's
development do you have sympathy for
women who feel like they just mentally
cannot handle it what's your thoughts
they need better mental health care we
need better mental health care and they
need to be connected to mental health
resources that resources that do exist
killing the child is not going to give
you better mental health it actually
will deteriorate your mental health and
studies that have been done have proved
that in the year after a woman has an
abortion versus if she had chosen to
have give birth and let that baby live
she's 150 more likely to commit suicide
so if you want to talk about women's
mental health abortion is only going to
deteriorate her health thoughts and then
i'm going to go to the next question to
you
i mean i absolutely agree mental health
care is an egregious
abortion it's not mental health care
it deteriorates mental health as well as
kills a child i yeah i don't think
abortion should be a solve for any
mental health issue
but again because that infrastructure
doesn't exist and we are not providing
that on a nationwide scale i think it is
too pie in the sky to put into action
before it actually exists because if
we're forcing birth as early as june or
july if roe v wade is overturned it
probably will be we don't have any
infrastructure in place for anything
that i described in this conversation to
support that influx of children to
support the people who are suffering
through mental okay so do women need to
rely on abortion to succeed in society
and if they do is that a good thing
oh
good thing um
again because i am a single working
mother i am struggling financially
because there is no child care for my
son until he's five or there's no school
until he's five that's provided so
absolutely it holds me back in my career
and
it i could get much more accomplished he
would also benefit so much from the
socialization and the ability to be
around other kids that's something that
i cannot financially provide for him
right now because again there's no
structure in place to help me with that
so
that's just my experience and i know i
am a very very privileged person and
that's a privileged experience still
because there are many women who are
literally working multiple jobs for a
minimum wage that doesn't amount to
anything to support their existing
children and
they are not able to pull them you can't
pull your bootstraps out of that
situation there's not enough support
quick answer on the thoughts on the
question i just asked her about like do
women need to
rely on abortion and then i have another
question for you i think that we need to
double down on the existing support
systems shore them up improve them
a lot of that's what the day in day at
work besides educational work and
lobbying work which is what live action
does in other groups there are a
thousand work is like just
just for the prevention of abortion not
to lobby to have all of these things
that you believe in in place like well
we're for child tax credits for families
and i'm asking curious as an as an
example as far as other public policy
options paid family leave child tax
credits for so you're lobbying for these
things yes we've probably yeah yeah
that's what there's great something we
found common ground on oh my gosh
but i think they're you know what's
heartbreaking because i don't see that a
lot in that party what's har well i
don't i i mean you're talking about
parties it's uh there's a lot of
progressives and democrats who are
pro-life so i think it's you can find
them in both parties but um i think it
what is heartbreaking to me is that we
have women who are not being connected
right now to the resources that do exist
in communities and one of the primary
reasons for that is because of planned
parenthood because they are staking
ground as the place to go and saying we
are there for you and they're getting
the taxpayer dollars for it and they're
getting the marketing dollars for it and
they're getting the you know celebrity
support for it and they're even getting
corporate support for it and they're
actually not providing options for women
they're getting all of that privilege
and support to what then go saying
here's a here's an abortion for you
instead of here's the prenatal care has
so that's what i would advocate is for
shut that whole
lethal business down and replace all
that societal cachet all that financial
support and put them into the
organizations that are actually solving
problems for women and providing care
for their for their children is that
something you could get on board with
possibly well somewhat i just i think
money should be really reallocated in so
many ways we spend but planned
parenthood doesn't want pro-life centers
to get in fact
there are pro-abortion activists right
now that are literally throwing molotov
cocktails into pregnancy resource
centers and planned parenthood happening
in the reverse forever too i mean
there's egregious behavior on both sides
but i'm not seeing it decried by
planned parenthood right now i mean
they're kind of the lead and i'm not
surprised because they're for abortion i
can totally understand your rub with
planned parenthood
my issue is that again an organization
like that sprouted out of a need that
wasn't being met and the need it was
sprouted from
a myriad of other needs that lead to
that so i yeah okay next question sorry
what about overpopulation lila is having
more people around bad for the planet
well first of all overpopulation can if
it exists could never be solved by
killing part of the population
so you know abortion's never
the answer you don't kill off your
youngest members most vulnerable members
to solve population issues
but we're actually facing a population
crisis under population right now in
much of the western world so in most of
europe they're not replacing their own
populations their populations are
shrinking and the
population demographic is increasingly
elderly and less young and so that
imbalance is creating huge economic and
social problems
there aren't enough people to care for
an aging population as an example and
that's happening in the united states as
well and part of it is because of the
fearful rhetoric around birth motherhood
and children where we are saying it's so
hard it's so bad it's so negative you
should have the abortion or we're saying
you can't have a career without having
an abortion or all of that negativity
around life
is a huge driver of the population
crisis and
you know the solution to that again i
can go back to what i was saying before
it's education
it's connecting people to the resources
that they need it's a mindset shift
about we're here to support each other
and a child is not a threat it's not an
enemy it's part of the family now we're
going to fight for each other have a
fighting spirit about it that needs to
be
the um the focus for for the
underpopulation crisis not not just to
solve under popular population i mean
life is worth fighting for it's up for
in and of itself but it certainly would
help prevent some of the looming
economic
issues because of that crisis
thoughts or
well bringing up economics is is so
complicated and and
nuanced as well because
we created a population that's like
working class that's living in
capitalism and it's not working for
everyone and it hasn't worked for
everyone for a long time and we're
seeing that disparity more and more all
the time so
the term like population crisis is
really conflicting to me because i don't
think there's any crisis in people
choosing to not have a child let's just
say by means of condoms and birth
control like just actively being like
i'm in a family plan i'm going to do
this when i want to there's a lot of
women who are as an example
delaying pregnancy
for many years for many different
reasons that later on regret it i mean
there is a you have to admit there's a
societal push it's not like just
everyone makes their own decision and
there's no pressures on them i think
there is definitely a societal push
today to
say that you should delay having kids or
having children is going to hold you
back i mean there's a lot of negativity
not around absolutely and there are a
lot of challenges around it too those
challenges are that's the thing there
there is fear-mongering around it i
don't even like when people are like
saying like it's hard i hate it like i
don't like all of that rhetoric either
that's just my personal opinion because
i love being a mom and i see so much
beauty in it
so
again it's not so black and white of
like this movement is saying that it's
bad i think the distinction is that my
side of the aisle is saying
that
it is so hard there is so much undue
burden because of everything that i have
talked about like if we had not had to
deal with undue burden or if i had
access to get my son into school
tomorrow or yesterday it would be a
different story for me in my career and
what i was able to do and capable of and
under capitalism and the way the economy
works now which really doesn't work for
the majority of us
that creates something that feels like
an economic crisis because it doesn't
work for everybody and it's not
instigating people to want to bring new
life into this place
okay so i think we covered so much i i'm
gonna have to skip the last few
questions because i know we're on like a
timeline we've been going for such a
long time and it pains me to not ask
these last few questions but maybe we'll
do a part two or something
but the last question just to round it
out um i'll start with you lila and then
i'll let you finish the news is packed
to the brim about updates on roe v wade
which is the decision that declared
there was a right to choose abortion as
a federal law in the constitution
as of the time of this recording the
supreme court looks like they might
overturn it do you think the court will
overturn roe and what will that mean for
our national conversation about abortion
you answer then you answer and then
we're done
thank you ellen thank you for hosting
thank you brenda for the conversation uh
roe v wade i think will fall i think
that at least the court will do damage
to it it was unjust it was illogical
um it's created huge devastation over 63
million children have been killed since
uh roe v wade became the law of the land
in 1973.
it's just the beginning though because
what would happen if this court chooses
to overrule roe is they will likely as
they say have the states decide abortion
and that's not the ultimate solution i
mean it's not up for state legislatures
to decide who lives and dies within
their state those children deserve all
of them legal protection whether they're
um in a blue state or a red state or no
matter that no matter the state that
they're in so i think that we have to
get better get to work our movement is
just getting started both to provide
legal protection in the states that we
can if roe v wade is overturned
um to continue to advocate for the
national right to life that all of us
possess i think it's a constitutional
right under the 14th amendment the 14th
amendment says that we have um we
deserve equal protection under the law
and that no state has the right to
deprive someone of their life without
due process and that's certainly what's
happening to children in a state that
permits abortion so we should continue
to argue for that constitutional right
to life that all states should abide by
and then we got to work day in and day
out abolish abortion where we can
provide the support and the care for
women expand these organizations i've
been talking about get them to continue
to grow and continue to educate educate
people about the abortion procedure and
about human development about the
options that exist okay brenda you
i also think it'll fall and
i am devastated and i like cried my eyes
out when i really realize the gravity of
that and what it would mean for me and
for so many i just love people and i
care deeply about this issue and about
who it's going to affect negatively
which is going to be a lot of people
and
to me i truly believe that is
inhumane unjust and immoral to force
birth
and in doing so we are taking away the
autonomy in humanity we are dehumanizing
people in a vulnerable state
and removing that choice from them is
going to cause an exacerbated amount of
problems for mental health spiritual
health physical health all of it
i truly wish to see a world i actually
am fine
i know i want to say fine i don't want
to misspeak but roe v wade has flaws
that i would like to see amended i would
like to see a new something in place
where
lila and i and the things that we agree
on are addressed in a way that is
humanizing and full of love
and really promotes a culture of life
which is what i want
and
to me
removing this
like letting roe v wade fall
and
forcing people to give birth
it just it really hits it hits uh me
hard and i am just really sad to see it
because
the more humane way the path that i
think is real and true and like honoring
of what i believe spiritually would be
to foster an environment where we look
at everything on the table that causes
abortion and we amend all of those
issues one by one i think letting roe v
wade is an easy way would you ban
abortion then
you're saying if you did all that would
you then ban abortion if you somehow i
don't think abortion should ever be
banned i think it's inhumane to force
someone to give birth i think that we
can create a society together if we all
align and get on the same page about
what's truly important and fix those
issues one at a time which would take so
damn long and so much work you're doing
a lot of that work now but that would be
the humane thing to do and then if
someone is choosing an abortion it would
be truly
a rare case if we could amend the
reasons that people are getting
abortions in the first place the
misinformation they're receiving in the
clinic all of the things that you
brought up if both of our concerns were
amended and changed but people still had
the preservation of their autonomy and
right
that would be the world that i want to
live in and that's what i'm going to
strive for wow this is amazing this was
so good thank you guys so much i think
we're going to wrap it up i truly
appreciate you both coming on here and
like being so brave to come out and it
is it's quite brave and vulnerable not
many people are willing to do it so i
really appreciate the conversation and
we're going to end it here thank you
everybody for tuning in
[Music]
[Music]
you